Two,
one he
edge,
blah.
Yo my man.
I like how we could just start the podcast like this right off the fucking
commercial.
I noticed that like a week ago.
Change it.
The flow of the conversation made it way better.
Yeah,
that was bullshit because it was like,
you know,
when I really realized it was bullshit,
like a,
I did a podcast with Stan hope and he was making fun of the commercials.
I was doing it.
I was like,
why am I doing commercials in front of them?
Why don't I just do that later and stitch it in?
And I was lucky where the deal that I had for commercials was really just for
iTunes.
And so,
um,
like when I to do this,
it goes on youtube first.
So as it streamed on youtube and youstream no need for commercials.
Fuck it.
So,
and then I put the ads in later.
But on iTunes and on a,
on Youtube,
this is no commercials.
You know when it changes too,
is that this podcast is most of the time anyways is about just you and your
friends just talking about bullshit.
Yeah.
You're not getting right to,
it's not like use the Promo code every day.
Our,
he is our,
he just wrote a book and he's Outta here to promote it.
Sometimes that happens like Paul Stanley and stuff know I get a lot of those,
but it's still,
even with them it's like you would want to,
you want to sit them down and go,
so uh,
what's it like to write the book?
What,
you know,
how hard was it,
how long does it take?
Like what's the process conversation before the podcast.
Dot.
There is some serious conversations that's going on.
And then instead of just starting and starting the podcast on a dime and then
continuing the conversation,
he hit the commercials and you'd never get back to that conversation.
A lot of the times that's happened.
Well you know,
a lot of times like we haven't seen each other in like a week or two and we got
a bunch of crazy shit to say to each other and you just start balling and then
by the time the podcast starts,
so what's up man?
You know,
you learn,
you learn a lot about yourself.
Like I'm listening to you listen to your own podcast.
I listened to the good ones.
I don't at all,
I can't,
I can't stand this.
I have no desire to listen to myself.
The only time is when I'm going through mastering the system,
my tutorial,
I do sit there and I am interested in how I'm teaching and what I said and how I
could have made the point clearer in my teaching.
So I,
I uh,
that's the only time,
but when it's a podcast and I'm not talking about you just said,
I'm just talking about like just bullshit.
I don't want to hear myself.
It's good to hear though.
But for the same reason like you realize why you were annoying to you like I
have,
I've found things that I didn't know I did like little s little ticks,
little weird things like people do like a big one is saying like people,
like there's like Tom Segura,
I love him to death.
That mother fucker out likes me.
He hurts me sometimes.
Like there's like a way like if you got like a guy like in his like a way like
ah,
did he say that or everybody does and we all do it.
We don't even know what guys are telling the story.
It's hilarious.
And
he's like,
she came up to me and started mad dogging me and I was like,
what the fuck you look in that I paid for all that shit.
And you didn't say none of that.
You just said I was like that I had that look on my face but I didn't say shit.
And if you don't question did you actually say that you're like,
no.
I was like,
I was,
I was thinking it I to you would have made it seem like he was just bad mother
fucker and this story saying you didn't say shit.
And I was like,
fuck you pay for that shit.
He said that.
No,
no.
I thought it like I thought it.
Fuck you and all and where you came from pitch.
Do you actually say it to him?
No,
I hate that.
Another one that I do that I need to figure out how to stop doing.
As you say.
I say,
you know,
I don't know.
You know,
it's like,
you know,
you know like you're trying to form your point.
You're trying to like formulate it in your mind and now you,
you know,
you sympathize more with black people when they're always saying,
you know what I'm saying?
You're like,
we're basically doing the same thing.
We're just not,
not saying why are we making fun?
I know what I mean.
Everybody says,
you know,
they just say no what I'm saying.
But if they stretched it out further,
it would get even more ridiculous.
You know what I'm saying?
We're gone.
Word God.
If like,
you know what I'm saying?
It was like in the middle of every sentence.
I think he started something.
I think I'm out of star or something.
You know what I'm saying?
Work on,
what did you say?
Hashtag [inaudible] do you know what I'm saying?
Word Guy.
Yeah.
Well,
black guys were calling each other God for awhile on the east coast.
It was a weird thing that was going on.
Like I went to,
uh,
I went to see Terry Norris fight,
um,
uh,
at a bar with a friend of mine who's a comic and his buddy,
they will,
we work together and me and this,
this comic,
and he brought his buddy with him and we all went to,
we had Terry nars fighting tonight,
let's go.
I'm going to see Tara Norris fight live on whatever it was,
HBO and they,
they were talking to each other and they were talking to Matt.
He hit him with that left hook.
God,
you see that Jab,
a head movement God.
And I was like,
Whoa,
what are they doing?
Like is this a I,
you know,
I'm white obviously.
So I'm like,
what am I missed a meeting like this is,
it seems to be a new thing.
And then I remember shaking my head going,
this will not last you guys where you're going to feel silly for calling each
other God and a couple of years.
You can't just do this or maybe,
you know what
a lot of people are trying to come up with their own shit and try to make it
stick.
You know,
some of it that was all panning out.
Some doesn't,
but people are,
they're trying.
That was a big one though.
That was everywhere.
It wasn't like these guys,
it was their shit.
It was like black guys were doing that all throughout the east coast in the 90s.
It's very prestigious to have your,
you're a San,
you made up blow up.
Oh yeah.
There's one,
you know,
people always say,
Holler at me,
Holler at me.
Yeah.
Uh,
this guy,
uh,
Rico Santana,
he started scream at me.
He was pushing that scream at me,
scream at them and uh,
I'm not sure if it's stuck.
Never heard it.
When did he do this?
How long ago?
Five years ago it was,
we'll try their own chest tag.
Scream at me.
Yeah.
You don't,
you want to punch someone to Holla at Ya.
But Hala is what's up.
You know,
this is not scream at you implies like they're angry at you.
You're like,
you're setting yourself up for,
I like it.
Scream at me,
scream at me,
bitch screaming man.
But you say it like in a sexy.
Oh,
okay.
Right.
Like you tell the chick screen touch.
Eric's gonna stop calling you.
She's going to run a wash.
Dot.
I'm not gonna respond to your text now.
It's going to be like,
come on Z.
Imagine that instead of call me later.
Scream at me.
I said,
if you said it like that.
Well you're a funny guy.
So you said it like that.
It will probably work because she would,
she would start laughing,
you know?
Speeding.
Alright,
well listen,
you like to die but you later.
Oh that's going to work for a women.
How the fuck did those ticks?
Like little things like that.
Like,
you know what I'm saying?
You know,
it's like,
like where are those coming from?
And then they're basically the complicated versus ah,
even fucking like a lot of times people will use fucking fucking fucking guy was
his fucking same thing.
That's all there.
They're elongated version.
Fucking is the worst.
Right?
Do that a lot too.
I used to,
when you're younger you do that more and you're nervous,
nervous.
There's a lot of fucking nervous like fuck man.
And then I was like fucking,
and he was like,
fucking,
I don't give a fuck.
And I was like,
fucking fuck that dude.
When I was doing standup in Boston date,
they had a thing they used to call the fuck meter.
There was saying like if you're going to go do standup,
they would say,
Eddie,
don't break the fuck meter.
Like when you use them,
they should mean something.
And there was,
there were so right.
It taught me so much because when I see a guy who says,
fuck too much,
I know that guys nervous.
You know,
if he starts fuckings fucking I'm walking down the fucking street and this
fucking chick fucking,
it's like you're off.
There's something off your,
you're,
you're using one word too many times,
no matter what word it is.
And if it happens to be fucking like you're trying to sound like you're
together,
you're trying to sound like you're upset,
but you're not really,
or if you're,
if you are upset,
you need to collect your thoughts,
you know,
and that that's what he hear.
That when you listen to a podcast,
whereas is you just thought,
most of the time you're just talking.
You don't,
you don't remember how you said it.
You just don't.
Very little.
Very rarely,
unless something really crazy happens.
You know how often you really remember how he said things?
What's a buddy?
No,
I'm just thinking,
man.
I bet her head say it's something that I probably should not talk,
but it's funny to me,
but it's not podcast material.
Oh,
sorry.
The one thing that I had,
Eddie Bravo,
we'll write that down,
Jamie.
We're getting,
is it not a chance in hell?
Are you gonna remember what we talked about?
Either.
That's the word.
I mean,
maybe I will write it in my notes.
Oh Man.
Notes are huge.
God dammit.
Do you use notes when you do your notes for every motherfucking do you do them
for seminars or did everything really?
All my notes.
Like on your phone,
you've ever read thing?
I you transcribe it.
All my shit.
Do,
do,
do the voice transcription thing.
No.
Oh,
it's so good dude.
So good.
So accurate.
It's kind of,
yeah,
I use it all the time.
Like if I'm in my car and I got an idea,
I used to get panicky.
I be like,
fuck,
I got to pull over.
And it started coming up with reasons to say the idea over and over and over
again so that I didn't forget it.
Now just grab that phone and hit that button and go blah,
blah,
blah.
Put it down.
I'm gone.
Yeah,
there's,
I use it for Jujitsu a lot for teaching.
There's so much shit to master and she gets,
it's so vast.
It seems like it's getting crazier to,
with the advent,
like the more attention that people would putting on leg locks these days.
It seems like I'm watching Jujitsu and I'm like,
man,
I'm not,
you know,
I s I see transitions on the ground that I understand,
but when I see some leg lock transitions,
I'm like,
I have no idea where these guys are going.
Yeah,
I just see scrambles.
I'm going to show he's a,
I'd have to watch that again and again and again.
See how he set that up.
Yeah,
you just got to get it broken down to you and in a system,
just like the rubber guard,
cause you would have,
you have fifth degree,
six degree,
eighth degree black belts out there and Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and they've never
really looked into the rubber guard at all.
And they think,
oh they just throw on their legs up and they're grabbing their leg and then
there's an arm bar or triangle on a guys slip out and then they're just grabbing
their ankles.
They don't realize how precise and microscopic it is.
And uh,
that's what I used to think of.
Leg locks and leg locks where you just jump on legs.
I'm a black belt and I'm still thinking this until about a year ago.
I bought dude's just jumping on.
You get that outside one or you get that inside one.
I was pretty good at a heel hook comment off being mounted.
Uh,
but I didn't spend a lot of time with your hooks.
It just seemed like,
Ooh,
I don't want to get my uh,
you know,
MMA fighters.
I want to set up a good MMA example cause I'm not going to be the one going in
the cage.
So if I'm trying to teach them to shit,
I better be doing this shit.
So,
so I thought it's not a good idea to,
to always go for leg locks.
If,
if you're going to do MMA,
it's uh,
it's a great like second or third option,
last resort,
nothing's working.
You can't take the guy down.
You tried and maybe you almost got them down.
You almost pass the guard.
The guy's a beast.
It's not working,
nothing's working.
He's throwing you around,
It's a third round.
You might tell this guy if,
if this guy in the gym was really good at leg locks,
this is where your town let's fucking go after his legs is uh,
the chokes aren't working.
We're not getting anywhere near his neck.
You got one more round.
Thank God that you could actually pull this off because you're really good at
leg locks.
That's,
that's what it was like a last ditch effort.
Yeah.
Resort if shitting
work cause it's risky,
they can work,
but if they don't work and on the bottom you're going to get Alan belcherd.
You know what I'm saying?
And uh,
the,
uh,
the best leg locker in the game right now as Eddie Cummings,
he,
uh,
he's an Ebi one 45 champion.
He,
he's incredible.
He's incredible.
He's like the more Garcia of leg locks.
You say I'm Alan Belcher's.
We should explain what you mean.
Like when he fought Paul Horez,
Paul Harris,
who's like the best leg locker and MMA,
Alan Belcher thought long and hard about this and worked a lot on the strategy
and did a lot of leg locked.
He brought in,
he flew and he,
he trains in Tennessee,
Alabama.
I said,
Alabama guy to Biloxi,
Mississippi.
I mean,
he's got his gym now.
I forgot,
I forgot one of those places down in [inaudible],
but he flew in Dean lister for that fight and Dobby Ramos who just won Abu
Dhabi,
that guy's an animal,
saw that flying arm bar.
That guy's,
that guy's a new,
uh,
new,
the new star in town and he's got to be Ronald cause brass.
Alan Belcher,
three years ago,
two years ago,
whenever that fight was,
it was probably at least three years ago when that happened.
When his fight with Rusa,
Paul Hersey flew both of them in and he was already known it as a really good
leg locker and yoked and shit.
It looks like a mini little Paul Harris,
a little smaller.
And Alan Belcher said,
Dean lister and Dobby Ramos just rectum with legs for a month straight.
Just wrecked them and he just forced them,
forced them to learn.
Little by little,
you're fine,
you're safe spots.
You figure out where you're safe and maybe you're not getting out or escaping.
But let's figure out where we could stay safe and then we'll think about the
escape later.
You know,
that's how it all started.
And then you get really good at boom at staying at then say,
just gone right through that safe zone who write to the escapes because you
know,
you've done it so much the slow way and then it starts blending little by little
boom.
Uh,
but anyways,
uh,
Alan Belcher eventually learned how to deal with leg locks amazingly.
Yeah.
And then he proved it in the octagon,
in the UFC against the scariest leg lock out there.
Still to this day,
still the scariest leg lock out there.
And Paul Harris had many shots at Allen's leg.
He would escape and then Rusa more parts has this elaborate system.
He knows exactly what he's doing.
It's,
it's,
you have to spend a lot of time there and really analyze the possibilities and
all the angles when you're attacking legs.
It really is an entirely different system,
just lens.
But we're also learning that it's not a be all end all,
especially in MMA.
Paul Harris has been jacked a couple of times.
And even the best guy right now,
Eddie Cummings,
when he goes in and he competes,
he's tapping everybody with heel hooks,
but he needs two or three tries at those legs.
Guys going to defend the first time.
It's always the same was matters.
You'll get guys really quick to 30 seconds,
12 seconds,
boom.
He just jumps on and he's like,
dude,
you're
like,
oh shit.
You know,
he has,
but generally against the top guy,
the guy's gonna pull out of a shit like two or three times.
Eddie might just let them,
let them think that,
oh look,
I can't control them.
And then just setting them up,
just playing with the,
letting them go and then coming back.
Just knowing that he's going to get those legs eventually wearing you out even.
Yes.
And then button MMA,
man,
you got to go in there to better work that first fucking time because I've,
that guy's finds a little safe zone and he has a safe zone where he could punch
you.
It could be lights out.
Yeah.
Risky.
Very dangerous.
So regardless of,
uh,
how,
sophisticated and awesome leg locks our overall right now in grappling still in
MMA,
they're still dangerous.
But,
uh,
it's very important secret weapon when you know the safe,
safer stuff,
like,
you know,
taking them down and passing and scarred and mounting them and getting his back
and nice and safe.
You're not going to reverse shit on me.
I'm going to,
you can't punch me.
You can't punch me.
I'm all over you.
Boom,
Bam,
nice and safe and dominating.
You know,
it's always a,
a better idea to try to do that first.
If you can do that,
why would you give him a chance at your face while you're gone for leg locks?
You might get it,
but you're giving them a shot,
man.
All he's got to do is be a little bit good at d,
defending a little bit,
defend that shit.
He's used to it.
Pam,
done.
If,
especially if you've got a guy,
you remember that Cro,
cop,
Gonzaga fight,
the last one or cro cop was on top of Gonzaga and blasting and with elbows.
And you saw what happens when you get a scary,
scary striker like cro cop on top of you and you're not controlling his posture.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Can't forget that kind of shit.
Can't forget that because cro cop might be the only guy we've seen do it like
that to it that quickly.
Devastatingly.
But that means it's possible.
Like you,
it just cause you're in someone's guard that she doesn't save.
You know,
like Tito didn't ever,
and Tito never had the kind of um,
the kind of speed and precision as a striker.
The Cro cop has,
so Krakow's elbows,
even as short,
elbows are just so devastating.
But Tito use to fuck guys up from inside their guard.
The even never bothered pass and people's guard,
it's like good luck holding on and me boom.
And he would just jack guys.
And the best ever was Uriah Faber.
Nobody threw elbows better than him cause he was so small and it,
his opponent was so small,
he could lie.
Lay in,
pray in someone's full guard,
lamb,
pray,
lay on him.
Just because he top guys got us clinch to bottom guys throwing elbows.
Bottom guy could punish.
So you're,
you know,
if you're in someone's guard,
you're in some danger with strikes to and submissions.
If the guy knows what he's doing.
But he would pick dudes up,
he'd be land pray,
but then he would like spring up,
like he's doing some kind of like back extension.
He'd pick them up and then slam them on the ground,
followed by an elder,
like a rhythm.
Papa,
Papa.
He'd lift him up.
He lifted him up.
I was a fucking amazing rhythm.
That was the king of the cage days,
right?
No,
that was WEC days.
That was before the UFC bought the WDC.
This was back when it was
somewhere in San Luis Obispo or some shit.
It's way up north.
Right?
Yeah.
And he used to fuck people up like that.
But then he learned how to pass the guard and he got really good at Jujitsu.
So,
so instead of standing there,
he thought even this guy with the most devastating ground and pound,
you don't see it anymore because he's going to try to pass the guard and mount
you and take it back and choke you.
He knows the way now is geared teens too is when he gets a hold of dudes next.
He's so nasty.
Yeah.
Cause good teens are just so tight.
Quick.
When you think of someone,
you think you try to think of a UFC fighter who's known,
who's known for a special submission that like you,
like Rhonda,
you're like arm bar.
Ronda armbar battles to ask.
You know what I mean?
Pam,
there's only a few guys that you see the submission right next to him,
right when someone talks about him and your ifa,
but he's got that little,
that little special guillotine.
He does are so many different ways to guillotine,
uh,
next so many different ways and the way that,
um,
Uriah faber doesn't,
I'm,
I'm not even good at that way.
I never been getting that position.
I never find myself in that one.
It's like a whole beautiful little path and just to dangerous chuck,
I really got to sit down and look into it.
Really now that I'm thinking about and talking to him,
I'm like,
what am I doing?
I've got to say there's just so much to do.
That was the beginning of this conversation.
There's so much to teach after write shit in my notes.
Boom.
I brought it back.
That's the one thing that I hate listening to myself talk is cause I'll have
like a story I want to say,
but then I think,
okay,
let me set it up.
So when I'm listening to my shit,
I used to listen to my podcast and I see it and I'm dissecting like what I do.
I'm like,
I'm trying to make a point,
but I never get to the point because I go so far back to set it up that by the
time I get to the point I already thought of another story and I go way over
here and a,
it's called weed.
Yes.
I hate that about me.
Shit.
So when I hear myself doing,
I go,
there,
I go start,
I'm talking about something else.
Never even finished the fucking point.
I had a good point too and I just forgot about it.
I never got to it.
It's,
we all do that.
It's when you get high,
I digress so much and then it becomes a game.
Like let's try to figure out where this all started.
We're trying to backtrack.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Okay.
We do the exact same thing.
Yeah,
I do it all the time on this podcast.
If we get high,
I just goes on its own.
You know,
it's like you began to excel.
Maybe we should let people know before the podcast.
This is a marijuana induced podcasts.
Some of them are so,
or this one's not.
So there you go.
If you,
if you're like going,
what the fuck are they talking about?
Well that does that too.
We decides what you want to talk about.
Yeah.
And now you've got Ryan Hall,
man,
that's a,
now we got a little dude who's coming in with the uh,
who some are porous type threat to the legs as well.
How good is he going to do?
And you know what a stand it looks like a split
works together.
He looks like he's got,
you know,
decent striking.
It looks like he knows how to move on his feet and uh,
he's been at Tristar so you know,
it's working as rustling all the Goddamn time.
Is his wrestling going to be good enough to take anybody down in the top 10?
Wayne,
what is it competing at one 45 and he's going to stay there?
Or is it going to go to 35 I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
A lot of times they do tough at a weight class above,
I think because if you're gonna make the extreme weight cut that a lot of guys
make,
you're going to need six to eight weeks.
Whereas if you're on tough,
you got to do it multiple times over the course of six weeks.
And for a lot of dudes,
like almost everybody started out a higher weight class.
Michael Bisping,
you know he competed at two Oh five and beat a lot of guys at two oh five he
fought on the ultimate fighter to a five one 85 is a better way class for him.
Yeah,
same with Calvin.
Calvin wanted at one 85 but he's better at one 70 yeah.
It's almost like if you're going to do the ultimate fighter,
you do your walk around,
wait,
do your set.
Like if you had to do something same day,
weigh in,
do that way.
That's always the next weight category and that she wanted to get super crazy.
Some guys just say fuck it.
Same Day when I'm still going to cut like a motherfucker.
I just think when you're on that show and you going to do that several times
over six weeks and then on top of that,
it's the nerves and all the TV cameras.
Your first experience,
you better off just not being,
not doing anything that's gonna Drain you.
He might go to 35.
I mean,
I,
I mean how does he look at 45 he's kind of like a skinny winery guy at 45 right
now.
So far in the house.
I think he has,
he had one fight and he had a fight to get in.
Uh,
so far with just those two fights.
He's already world renown leg lock.
Master Uriah on the show.
You want you to shadow?
I haven't seen the season at all,
dude.
Come on.
I got to record it and watch.
I binge-watch tough with Conor McGregor.
Holy motherfucking shit.
How good at it.
But it's like the best ever.
Are you kidding?
That's the best motherfucking puff of all time.
That's the best one.
How are you going to get better than Conor McGregor on your Goddamn TV show that
a fight show.
Oh Man.
He gets under your eyes.
Scan all.
He starts a lot of Shit,
man.
He's the ultimate shit talk.
Isn't it fucked up that he called Tj Dillashaw snake in the grass and they wind
up leaving.
That's crazy.
That's some profit shit.
That's some old Celtic warrior shit.
Mcgregor.
Just calling it like he just figures if he just calls it like he sees it.
Yeah,
no,
no filter.
Just call it like you see it.
Don't hold it in just no editing.
Just let it all.
He's,
he's from Dublin like they,
they talk mad shit over there dude.
It's a totally different style of shit.
Ton of the ultimate,
the ultimate tough would be chail coaching one team and Mcgon or coaching
another team and their weight.
They're different weight classes.
It's like chill could walk around at two 30 you know,
if he's not fighting,
he's way bigger than Connor.
So,
but so alpha,
he's not going to jail is going to like,
like big brother him and go oh come on at first like come on,
come on,
you're too small for me.
Chair would find a workaround.
The would figure out an unorthodox approach to dealing with Co.
He would,
he would deal like,
listen,
you're,
you're 160 pounds,
160 cute fella here.
And then the [inaudible] going to take that Connor is not going to sit there and
be the little one 60 pound.
You know,
a tiny little fighter to jail.
He's not going to big brother and I think he's bigger than one 60 I really do.
It's like one seven year,
whatever,
which is crazy that he fights at one 45 think about the shit talking between
them to hold credible,
you'd have to get chill off of his suspension.
He's got a two year suspension,
then c and then kind of went after agree to fight them in a catch weight and
it'll end up being condo.
Let's meet at one 80 if you can get down to one 81 85 or maybe Connor just says,
fuck it,
we're going to fight free weight.
Absolute Bitch.
Well,
I mean,
Connor and Rye aren't fighting.
I mean the show's hilarious and they're not fighting.
The coaches don't need to compete against each other at the end for it to be
good.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
I don't need that.
That would just happen because ICAN ICAN or wouldn't be able to take a kind of,
would call him out and say,
let's do this shit.
You know?
It'd be interesting.
It'd be interesting to see someone,
a coach opposite Ronda,
like a dude,
a dude coach opposite are raw Connor and Rhonda.
Rhonda to try would crush a ratings that would break the fucking take it.
That would be the greatest ratings of all time.
There would be no greater Connor and Rhonda together on a show.
And what if they wound up having an affair?
Oh,
it'd be giant news.
Dana probably would probably pull them aside.
Give him some ecstasy.
You guys want to make,
you want to make a lot of money.
You want matching
like
Angelina Jollie there I,
yeah,
them fucking so,
I'm a loping together.
It'd be so similar.
That's a Larry exact same thing.
It would be the exact same motherfucking thing.
He's the real fight club and she's the number one check on the planet.
Who's,
who has more power than Angelina Jolie.
She can go to any goddamn country easily.
She wants to go go meet the president of fucking Uganda.
Oh,
she didn't make that happen.
Oh yeah.
Fuck he's gonna.
He's gonna send a private jet for,
well,
she's become like an ambassador for like,
it's not just going to get into anybody's house just to an actress.
She does so much humanitarian work.
She adopt.
How many kids?
Isn't that awesome?
It's amazing what they do.
I mean,
a lot of people trivial off trivialize it because we always have suspect
motives.
We always suspect like,
oh,
they're just doing it for the publicity.
Ah,
they're just,
she's just fucking crazy.
But at the end of the day,
she's adopting a bunch people and spending a bunch of time working to help all
these sick,
needy and poor people.
I mean,
she does some pretty incredible shit,
man.
That's a lot of positive energy.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it's probably why he or she's had the most amazing career ever.
I mean,
she's hot and everything,
but there's a lot of hot chicks out there.
She's,
she remains relevant because of all that philanthropy was like,
she wouldn't be,
she wouldn't be doing all that she's doing if she didn't appreciate life way
more than the average person.
So she's living in a state of appreciation so much.
He's been wanting to give back so much and change the world.
She's so into it and that's just like a overproduction of appreciation and then
look at a career and then she comes out with,
she's,
she's a list all the way through.
Not only that,
even if her movies suck,
people just forget about them.
They just don't talk about him anymore.
Like Angelina Jolie socks.
But if they were going to do like a alien six with Angelina Jolie,
you'd be like,
Oh shit and Joel,
he's going to be in the alien movie.
Like you would never think like,
oh,
this is how bad the cast is.
She's done like that.
A Cinderella type movie.
It's kind of like a Disney super animated Cruella.
Right.
Something like that.
I don't know how big that was.
Maybe that Dell has got 100 million or something.
It was big.
It was big for kids.
Perfect for her.
Yeah,
she could do anything.
I mean like movie star Wise,
any,
any role that she really wants to pursue,
she could do for now.
You know,
as she gets into her forties there'll be harder and harder.
That's what it is for those women,
like those Meryl Streep type women who were just smashing it in the 80s just
killing it.
She's such a good actress.
God Damn,
she's good.
She's so believable.
It's just so,
but as they get like in their fifties and their sixties it's hard to find roles.
There's not a lot of movies made about 60 year old ladies,
you know like so you have like a support role that may or may not be juicy and
might be boring.
My mom,
once you start playing the moms,
well that was one of the things that Robin Williams was saying Rob Williams was
saying before he died that it was really getting really hard for him because the
only thing that he was being offered that were interesting at all,
we're like scale or sometimes not even scale,
like you have to do it for free.
No Way.
She's still cute.
He was.
He was,
but the things that he found interesting,
he would do these movies that were just,
they didn't have any money.
They didn't have any budget,
but those were the interesting like did you ever see that 24 hour film for 24
hour photo?
What was it called?
It was called 24 hour photo or something like that.
He played a psycho,
like a real cycle that likes startups.
Family.
Yeah.
It was that his last fucking cause that was last film.
No,
no,
no.
There was a few years ago,
but he started getting interested in doing these like small independent films
like that and you know,
they would offer him like a piece of the backend or something like that
probably.
But he had a huge nut.
He had a giant ass house up in like northern California one hour photo.
That's what it was.
Dude,
he was so good in that movie.
God Damn it.
You would never believe that he's a Holly.
You never believed that.
The same guy from Mork and Mindy would be this fucking creeper in one hour
photo.
He was awesome in it.
But um,
my point being he had um,
like a,
a state in northern California.
Those are worth like 20 million bucks.
He had like all these bills following his heart with these roles.
Crushed him.
No,
no,
no.
He had some serious physical issues.
You know,
he committed suicide for whatever reason,
only he knows,
but there was a lot going on.
He had Parkinson's disease.
He had some sort of dementia that apparently was coming on his,
his mind wasn't functioning very well.
His body was failing.
He had a massive heart attack.
And then in going through a heart surgery,
a doctor,
Mark Gordon,
you met Dr. Gordon,
right?
And your mother,
I'm a,
I dunno,
uh,
he's the one that does all the work with traumatic brain injury patients.
And he said that when people go through any type of a giant surgery like that,
like heart surgery,
well,
you have to be under for a long period of time.
A lot of times your hormonal system is devastated.
After that.
You're,
your body's like really fucked up and it can send you into a depression like the
recovery from a major like heart surgery,
like w what he,
what he had done is apparently like it's a devastating thing on your body,
takes a long time to recover from.
And in that recovery process he thinks that a lot of patients suffer from
massive depression and there's like a correlation between suicide attempts post
surgery that he thinks possibly could be attributed to devastating effect that
being under for a long period of times and then the trauma of the surgery can
have on you.
So he had a lot going that was wrong before he killed himself.
All the energy,
this is just me guessing this is like a bro Biology,
but I'm guessing
when you're going through something like that and you're about to die and gone
through some major surgery,
your body's like,
we're not thinking about being happy at all.
Right now we're thinking about being alive so it stops all Saratonin production
just to keep you alive and when you recover your shit is so depleted that maybe
that's why you're depressed.
That's me guessing.
It could be.
It's also could just be,
it's a massive strain on the system.
You know,
I saw one of the reasons why they would prescribe steroids after surgery is they
would prescribe it,
especially to athletes when they get injured,
not just to make them recover quickly,
but because during that recovery process,
your body's very weak.
Like when you're,
when you have some major shit going on with your body,
you have some major shit fixed like for the x amount of weeks afterwards,
depending upon how old you are and how healthy you are,
you feel wrecked.
You just feel wrecked.
It just like,
oh cause your body's like danger,
danger,
resources.
Dude,
we got screws in our fucking knee.
We have a a,
there's an incision,
there's stitches,
is screws in the Patella and in the bottom,
this is crazy.
He cut off piece of our a Patella tendon and stuffed it inside with the ACL.
Used to be,
there's no ACL.
All this inflammation like your body's on just like crash alert.
Your body knows some pretty devastating severe shit has happened to it.
So,
uh,
I think depending on,
upon how healthy you are,
it's,
it can be a rough times afterwards.
And I think for an older dude like him who already has these physical issues,
I dunno if Parkinson's happened before or if he had had the symptoms,
how did he kill himself again?
Johann themselves.
Damn.
Yeah,
man.
Is that,
uh,
common quick way to go and suicide people do that.
They want to suffer a little bit.
They do have,
they don't want to shoot themselves or they don't,
or they don't want to suffer from pills.
You know,
there's only a few ways to go.
Hmm.
Um,
California actually just passed a law for assisted suicide,
which is going to be interesting.
I don't know the particular details of the law,
but,
uh,
when people are terminally ill,
like if you're dying of cancer or something like that and you're just in agony
every day,
um,
now finally you can end your own life and you can have doctor assisted suicide.
You know,
they'd been doing it to people either on the sneak tip or you people have had to
go to states where it's legal.
Like I believe it's legal in Oregon,
but now it's going to be legal here too.
It's amazing that you can't,
you,
you have to
eventually everyone has to think about shit.
Like put the dog down.
Okay.
Your dogs and agony,
you put your dog down.
But not grandpa.
GRANDPA's got a suffer grandpa's got to just keep shitting his pants and
throwing up and falling down and breaking all his bones and then stitch them
back together again and give him some pills.
And if grandpa was a dog,
you would've to put grandpa out a long time ago.
You know,
if Grandpa says,
look,
I'm ready to go.
You bring in the doctor,
the doctor.
Are you of sound mind?
Yes.
You know,
I'm 95 years old.
I had a great life.
I have wonderful family round.
I'd like to be around when I pass and that's it.
And you go,
which is probably a good way to go,
man.
It's probably a good way to go.
I think,
um,
the idea that you're supposed to suffer and make it to the end because it's
natural.
Well that,
that's not how we treat our cats.
You know,
if your cat is in fucking agony,
man,
you put your cat down,
he dog gets hit by a car and he's not going to make it and he's just howling.
You put your dog down.
This idea that people have to make it to some fucking finish line
darkness,
it is dark darkness,
brace that darkness.
Um,
those are the documents makes you appreciate the light,
you know,
that kind of shit and it makes you appreciate the light.
Yeah,
man.
It's like we're all going to have to deal with that sooner or later or you die
early.
I know one of the one or the other,
you're going to go through that old age and the hospital falling apart.
People taking care of you.
Everybody's going to go to that or you're going to die before that.
Yeah.
One of the other,
um,
my friend from Boston just died.
My boss when I was starting out too in standup comedy,
I stayed friends with him from a,
for the past 26 years,
has,
his name's Dave Dolan.
He was a private investigator.
And He,
uh,
he needed a,
um,
needed a driver because he lost his license with the Dui.
And he said,
fuck it,
I'm quitting drinking.
That's it.
But I need a driver cause he still had to work.
So we put an ad out in the want ads for a private investigators assistant.
And I,
uh,
answered the ad and I met this dude and he was fucking hilarious.
It was mostly insurance cases.
Occasionally it would be like a guy who thinks his wife cheating on him,
but most of it was insurance cases where people would pretend to be injured and
they would get,
they would get another job,
like working for cash under the table and he'd catch them because like the
insurance company was paying them millions of dollars or whatever they were
paying them and then they would go get another job.
Probably not millions,
you know,
um,
maybe there were suing,
whatever it was.
Most of these people,
they would get up early in the morning and go work other jobs.
So we would just wait.
So we would drive to this location,
go up the street.
So our car would be facing that house and we shut the car off and wait,
we get there at four o'clock in the morning,
but you're sitting there at four o'clock in the morning waiting for this dude
wake up and you should start talking shit.
And he would just talk shit.
He was hilarious.
Who would talk Shit Dave,
this Guy Day?
Yeah,
he was the one of the funniest people I've ever met in my life.
Like how old were you at this time?
I was 21 and you were just starting stand up.
I was just doing an open mic nights and I was still fighting.
He was on the last guy to see me fight and um,
he,
uh,
he would just talk shit,
talk shit about like,
he was one of those guys that like women could never ever get him to change.
Like it was impossible.
Like there was no,
there was no like,
what should I do?
Man,
she wants me to,
she wants me to change.
She wants me to change the way I'm dressing.
She wants me to move into some new neighborhood.
She wants me to quit my job and you know,
maybe I'm going to convert,
become Jewish.
There was none of that and that dude,
none from the moment I met him,
he was like,
fuck that.
You do that.
That's the beginning of the end pal.
Well listen,
that's how they get ya.
And he would always used to be laughing like never.
I don't,
I don't believe he was ever married.
They might've been.
But even if he was,
I'm sure that check had zero control over that guy.
Like I was crazy.
He was hilarious.
He was a guy that was meant to be a comedian that never became a comedian.
100% it could have been a worldclass comedian.
He was fucking funny.
And he was insightful.
And his cousin actually owned the comedy connection.
His cousin was built down,
so it was one of the owners of the comedy connection.
So I didn't even know this when I started working for him and he's asking me,
you know,
what do you do?
And a,
and I told him the whole deal and he was like,
my cousins Billy down.
So I'm like,
I do open mic nights there.
He's like,
no shit.
And so he easily like if he just decided to go and do it,
he just never did it.
He easily could have been a comedian.
He was fucking hilarious.
And we would do these things,
we would show up at people's houses and he would have like a list of license
plates.
And on one of those,
one of those license plates would be the,
the license plate of the person that we're looking at.
The other ones would be scratched out and maybe a couple more,
they just write a few in and get to this one.
And he would say,
listen,
my girl was in a hit and run and
this,
uh,
this guy,
he took off but someone got the plate and they didn't get it all,
but they got this amount of it,
you know,
and the guy was like,
well,
that definitely wasn't me.
Hey,
whoa.
Wow.
I'm so sorry to hear that.
Is She okay?
I go,
well,
she's going to be all right,
but she's got a,
a bulging disc and her l seven,
which is exactly what this guy's injury was and,
and the person would go,
that's crazy.
I have that same injury.
Oh,
no kidding.
Huh?
Well,
uh,
you,
you get into compensation and it got to be,
yeah,
you're getting paid and all.
Yeah.
It's great.
That payment,
and I'm also working under another name.
Like they would just tell you,
like,
this woman just told us that very story.
She told us she was working under her maiden name.
Then she had the same time for coffee.
This is how crazy people were in 1988 they have you in their fucking house for
coffee.
We didn't know this lady.
It was two men,
two men.
I mean me,
I was 21 and he,
he,
he was probably like 31 32 at the time.
And he had a center her fucking house and drink coffee with us.
And Dave's asking her,
so how do you work that?
And she's telling him,
you know,
I'll,
well you talked to choose my maiden name,
like,
so what happened?
He had tape recording.
No,
no,
he's just listening.
Just listening.
So he goes up.
So did you get hurt or he just bullshit the whole thing.
She'll,
how am I gonna hurt a little bit,
but I was fine.
So does that,
went to the doctor and the doctor looked at me like he gave up the whole
fucking,
she gave up the whole story and then we left.
I was like,
God,
I feel so bad we can't rat her out.
She was so nice.
He goes,
fuck her.
She goes,
she goes far car.
And I felt,
I felt terrible because this lady was so nice and she let us in on her scam and
I fuck her.
She's a fucking scammer.
Fuck her.
He would never ever show any sympathy for those people that will like scam an
insurance.
He's like,
that's what the,
that was the game.
It was like,
ah,
I'm the sheep dog.
You're the coyote.
I'm going to Jack you.
It's like that cartoon where they would go,
you wouldn't follow them.
You would just see him walking and then go up to them?
Totally depends.
Sometimes we would actually show up at the job site.
We catch a guy like on a roof with a fucking bag shingles on his,
on his bag,
just it just find out where the guy is,
find out what we'd take photos.
He had a camera,
take photos of the guy and go,
look,
this guy's working and that,
and then the would they usually it would happen,
I believe the way they would work at as an insurance company with threatened the
person and would say they're going to have him arrested for forgery and Fraud
Fraud Rather.
And then the person would either settle or they would maybe have to pay some of
the money back and they would just,
the insurance company just knew they're being scammed and they didn't want to.
Uh,
did you ever have to fucking anybody?
I'm no,
no,
no.
Nothing ever got ugly.
Nothing even got Yeley.
It was day 88 80 fucken eight.
Yeah.
Dave was like real good at talking to people.
He was like a,
he was a man,
but he loved it.
He loved the scam and people,
he loved it.
He just loved it.
So you're getting paid though,
aren't ya?
Like he would love like baiting them in and getting them to talk about it and
he'd get in the car and started laughing.
Ha ha ha.
That fucking dummy.
He
gave us everything.
Ah,
look at these photos.
Perfect.
He goes,
fuck.
he goes,
fuck him.
How Joey to him,
that would be a row.
I'd have to think about that.
I don't know man,
let me,
but he just died of cancer.
Just died of cancer last week real quick.
Apparently.
I just,
I just started getting some emails and messages about it and I was like,
no way and things.
The last time we talked to him,
last time I was in Boston just a few months ago and I was,
I'm going back to Boston in January and I was just going to get them tickets to
the fights and I was hoping,
uh,
you know,
have some dinner with them or something and hang out with them.
But we stayed friends.
We stayed friends all this time.
He was a good dude,
man.
He still stayed,
became,
you know,
stayed being a private investigator every now and then would call me up with
some crazy fucking story,
some crazy story.
One of them was this guy whose girlfriend was getting fucked by this
bodybuilder.
He,
she was,
uh,
she was meeting this gorilla who is just,
just bragged on or just,
just fucking savage fucking her.
And this guy kept wanting to get her followed.
Like the one guy,
the guy was like a real nerdy guys,
like computer guy and his girlfriend was just,
just,
just getting mauled all the time by this dude.
And he suspected it.
So we hired a private investigator and then David's like,
dude,
I can't keep taking pictures of your girl getting fucked by this giant guy.
It's starting to get creepy.
So,
uh,
we're done here,
but him telling him,
this guy's like,
oh,
go follow her.
And it was following tomorrow.
Are you looking at the pictures?
I'm looking at it because he would like take pictures of this guy just stopping.
He probably loves pictures.
Oh,
I bet he did.
Well,
he's probably a cuckold,
you know,
like that's what they say.
That's like a whole style porn now.
It's like a guy,
it's usually like black eyes,
like a white guy.
He's a nerd.
He's like,
yeah,
sure.
Come on in.
Like,
Oh man,
does your wife.
Oh Shit.
How is your wife was this hot?
Oh,
she has my wife.
I'm not sure if I want you talking about her like that.
Talk about fucker.
Bitch wants my Dick.
Oh,
she won't this Dick Bitch.
They look,
oh,
she's sucking my Dick Right in front of you.
There's a horn and there's an odd man.
There's all these old like husbands and she's like a feeble guy.
A feeble guy and a black eye.
Fucking shooting black guys.
No,
no,
no.
The Guy,
I'm sure this,
that was the white.
Yeah.
Most of the time the wife getting abused.
The husband never fucks as well.
I'm sure there's some of the husband fucks too.
I'm sure to some of the husband fun.
I'm sure that some of the hospital has the sucks guys deck,
like maybe the wife fucks the,
maybe the,
maybe the husband.
This is the ultimate car called the husband.
That's his hit there.
Why this giant fucking super athlete Fox,
his girl and then when the guy comes,
he comes in the husband's mouth.
It's the ultimate one.
It's the only time the husband sucks the guy's Dick,
but as he could get over here,
get your hair over here.
He puts the guy's head right down on the wife,
the wife's stomach while he just fucking plowing it and then he pulls it out and
stuffs it in the dude's mouth.
Right now someone's writing this down and then making this video probably
shooting it this week,
dude on Twitter sending me links it all right and exist.
The whole trilogy,
that's,
that's actually quite normal.
[inaudible] website.
Oh,
come on.
The husband's mouth.com you never been,
you don't even know that website,
Bro.
Yeah.
Whenever you can think of man,
when,
when we were first,
when you were first exposed to porn,
I was exposed like in high school.
That's when I first found out about porn.
It was also normal.
It was just the worst thing that would happen is two people get together and
they'd have sex.
That was it.
There's all that ever happened,
but then somewhere around the time,
like we were in Ife,
Germans
and the Japanese,
you mean Shit Porn.
That's not even porn.
That's just,
that's just fucking weird.
But even just regular porn became more about like gagging and fucking gagging.
Yeah.
Girls all do.
Even when they suck dick now it's like they're,
they're doing it like they're trying to kill themselves.
Is that the new commit suicide?
I didn't know that.
The gagging noises is good.
There's a lot of that dude.
You've never seen a lot of that.
It seems like people got bored with the regular stuff and then the got more and
more
gag at me.
Scream at me later and I'll make you gag too long.
Hashtag Hashtag screaming at me later and I'll make you gag.
Oh Man.
Well I was talking about this the other day with Chris Ryan that like porn,
like the look of the girl's vagina,
like shaved vaginas.
That's the only way now.
Like there's very few bushes.
If a girl has a Bush these days,
like she's taking a big chance.
She's being very eccentric.
But back then it was all bushes.
There was a point in time when I was like 22 that actually preferred a little
Bush because when girls would shave it would blank burn.
Like it would like Scaife my cock.
Oh we can know what I mean cause it's w yeah,
but when they left the kind of bushy,
it was all nice and squishy.
Phil player.
Good point.
I was really into it.
So that girl had a little Bush.
I'm like,
damn,
I'd like to squish into her some cross get all crazy lasered and shit.
They do their legs,
their Pussy Bang laser.
That shit isn't that nuts man.
That we use like a light beam.
We don't want hair on him.
Are there cultures where a girls with hairy legs are hot?
Must Be.
There's gotta be a couple of countries.
At least three.
Well how about that country in Africa?
Was it surgery where they cut their lips and they put plates in them and the
bigger the plate,
the more cattle you're worth when you get married.
Know what
fucking,
I want to know that story.
I want a document on how that happened.
Like the evolution of that big plate on that lip.
Like when
did it get cool?
Who brought it up?
Who is the,
who is the Helio Gracie of them lip fucking plates?
Who made that shit up?
You know what I mean?
And there's gotta be a story,
Karen Chelation
that the way they did it,
they made the girls lip like that so that she wouldn't be attractive to a
slave's slavers and people that were like trying to get slave.
How did it get to that point know that'd be like everyone agreed on that.
Well don't allow
people that have like a lot of like metal in their face and shit and a lot of
people have crazy piercings in their cheeks and their nose,
their lips.
Don't.
People usually say that that's a sign like,
and this is like,
this is total bro Psychology.
Right?
But that,
that's a sign of people that have been abused.
Isn't that like usually a sign of people that have had something like bad happen
to them?
Right.
And going to like back in olden times before that was mental institutions like
the crazy people of the village.
The town,
the big cities like them,
they can roam.
All the crazy people,
they just went out to the fucking jungle and started their own little culture
and uh,
some of them are fucking nuts.
Like who thought of the stories,
how the Romans get all the way to Africa.
Did they ever meet vendor that platelet?
Yeah,
I think it was probably,
I mean it makes sense
still if you look at like when you see,
okay,
if you see a girl with a bunch of shit in her face,
don't you immediately assume like,
ah,
girls probably molested.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Whether or not that's fair or not,
just just being honest.
Totally,
totally not true.
It's probably totally not true,
but you assume it.
Right.
Automatic because we,
we've,
we've developed a correlation between people that like,
like girls with face tattoos or five eyebrow rings and a nose ring and two lip
rings at a tongue ring.
Oh,
okay.
What's going on here?
There's definitely a,
the signs of the beast.
Like for me,
growing up with long hair,
that was a,
I thought when I was growing up,
you know,
my dad was never around and my stepdad didn't give a shit.
You know,
I thought that doesn't affect me.
I'm too strong.
1213 1516 that always thinking that never affected me.
I didn't need no fucking dad.
It was always that way.
That didn't affect me.
But when I look back at the pictures of my next big Mexican family,
there's all these normal looking people and then there's the dude.
I got the wedding with the long hose,
pissed off that he's there and not hanging out with his friends.
It was always me pissed pictures like just like this.
It was like normal for me to be like at the wedding at Dickinson Yetta at the
big W,
whatever Shindig.
Just pissed off that I'm not with my friends and playing music and listening to
slayer and shit and I thought I wasn't affected.
I was so affected.
I was a drummer in speed metal bands,
right.
And Satanic lyrics and I thought I wasn't affected.
My hair was long.
I was always in a pissed off mood like,
oh no,
I'm fine.
That's true.
I'm too strong for that shit.
My Dad,
I didn't give a shit,
but damn he,
he damaged me.
Of course those damage right there.
Shit.
Every kid that doesn't get paid attention to,
it's a core component of being a human being.
Like food,
like water,
like being out in the sun.
All those things are important for the development of a human being.
Attention and love from your family.
So it makes you a loving person.
Like you become loving when you're loved,
when you're not loved you,
you know,
you in inward,
you get angry,
you get aggressive.
That's what happens to people.
It's natural.
When you find people that are abused,
they're usually,
a lot of times those people wind up being abusive themselves.
They lash out.
You know?
I wonder if that is what happened with the Surrey women that that,
that they were being taken as slaves and so they just started doing fucked up
shit to their face to make themselves unattractive.
And they started their own little camp and then it turned into a village and
then blow.
It's a bunch of fucking crazy people started by like one crazy dude.
There's like the one dude is in those,
those,
those up piercing circus is,
what do you call those things?
You know that's like a hearing services.
Oh yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
Those crazy weird freak shows,
but with a lot of piercings and shit like that.
Like,
you know,
like at like a million,
they're hanging from fucking like some crazy.
I mean,
I'm done with tattoos,
you know that.
I liked that just,
but maybe not all over the face.
Generally.
Generally you want it a little bit,
you know what I mean?
Like the Mike Tyson one,
I like it now.
Mike Tyson is a bad motherfucker.
I like it.
You know?
And then you know,
Kat von d got some stars and Shit a little bit and you know,
the net ones are cool and all that shit too.
That's all.
But when you're hanging from a crane and you got these rings all around your
skull and they're hanging,
you're in Jesus.
There's something,
I want to know what happened
because something happened.
Something happened.
Maybe it was just like me,
maybe his father wasn't around and just think about your,
your situation was bad,
right?
But you,
we all know people who,
who was way worse and we like you,
you got through uninjured,
you know,
no one was raping you.
There's like you got through like relatively,
I never,
you know,
I wouldn't change a thing about my,
nor would I,
but a lot of people didn't.
Right.
And when you see like really fucked up people like really crazy out there
people,
a lot of times that's what they're reacting to.
Whatever kind of abuse it was,
right?
Whether it was sexual abuse,
where it was violence,
whether it was abandonment,
whatever it is,
whatever pain and hurting,
you know,
made them try to try to become something different.
I try to seek out others like her or like him,
you know,
that's what would people do when they formed these lights.
Like what you're talking about,
like being at the wedding.
I wanted to be with your friends.
I remember that exact same feeling.
I only felt normal when I was with my friends.
That's it.
Like every,
every time Alex,
I was like,
oh my God,
I can't be here.
I can't do this.
I don't want to do this.
I just got to go to my friends and everybody will,
will relax together.
We'll be able to talk and laugh and fuck off.
That was like always the appeal of a hanging out at the pool hall when I was
young,
when I,
when I started hanging out this place called executive billiards in white plains
with my friend Johnny that died from drugs.
Um,
that place
was just where we'd all,
we're all misfits.
I was like,
how the comedy store is,
that's it.
I,
Mitzi shore actually calls the comedy store,
the island of misfit toys that does like her nickname for it,
because all these weirdos come from all over the web,
but they all,
they go there and they realize when they're,
they're like,
these are the people like me.
There's other people like me.
I just had to find them.
I said to find these fuckers,
it just,
they weren't at the wedding,
they weren't at the Quinceanera back then.
Like when I look at movies from the eighties like in those movies you're looking
at people that are not connected.
They don't have that Internet phone that we got.
You know what I mean?
It's like that life,
there is no joke.
Everyone is disconnected.
Every,
the only thing that we were connected to was TV and radio,
the big networks.
That's the only way we can connect.
And you know,
people say that we're more connected now than ever.
We are in a lot of ways,
but in some ways because we weren't individually connected and there was only
one source,
NBC,
CBS,
ABC,
we actually,
that actually connected everybody and there's everyone listened to the radio
and,
and uh,
the radio stations are creating stars and everybody saw different strokes.
You went to school and like everyone saw eight 30 Friday night on NBC.
Everyone knew these are special spot.
That's how everyone got connected in the special eight o'clock on Thursday.
Cheers and shit.
Everyone got there.
We're so connected.
Way more connected now.
People aren't on those.
Like the radio doesn't have that much power.
I never listened to fucking radio ever.
I'm listening to like satellite radio and she ever listened to radio.
It's always sounded like so everyone is like less,
more connected to their niche,
but they're shit that's huge out there like this.
I was driving down the street and I saw this billboard in downtown La is a King
Daddy King Dad.
He's a white guy.
It'll or apparently is Latin,
but it looks like a white guy like vanilla ice and says King Daddy.
I thought it was like,
are they filming a fucking movie?
Like some kind of parody movie here?
That's what I thought it was like,
and then I looked at,
I go,
this is the craziest thing.
It's playing up the staples king dead.
I've never heard of him.
I Wikipedia,
he's fucking huge.
Like Holy Shit.
There's people that are huge and and because we're so disconnected with
everybody,
we're just connected more and more with the people that are like us and then
that's it.
Then we could shut everybody out.
We don't have to be all together but the old way and in that one way about NBC,
CBS and we all saw the news and 60 minutes we were at sometimes at those periods
we were all connected.
All of us both,
we were all like one,
we all knew the same shit,
but now we're all on our own planet now.
It's so true.
Like I'll go to someone's Twitter page and there are musicians.
I'm like,
who is this guy?
5 million Twitter followers.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I never heard of this boy would know that guy because we've got to all be on
those same channels.
Everybody would be on the same bay.
Now we're all,
we get our news from different places like do people still really watch news on
like Fox News?
It's like there's a lot of people that do them and easy.
There's not a lot.
Just a lot of people that do.
There's a lot of people that only like they'll,
they,
they only follow like right wing news sources.
So they have like a right wing news idea and that's the only thing they talk
about.
And so if they interact with something online,
look clearly you haven't been paying attention cause that's been debunked and
you're like,
okay,
how's it been debunked?
And you'll go and like read how it's been debunked,
done,
hadn't been deep bunked at all.
Everything is there any month deep debunk for a debunked bumped Fred
[inaudible],
Fred debunked every everything like debunked.
But it's really simple.
It's like where you get,
it's really a really is an info or just like Alex Jones says,
it really is,
it isn't about this theory.
And then that theory and the official story,
everyone goes to science but science that that is what uh,
people need to,
it's not just science,
it's unbiased.
Science can is,
where's the science coming from?
Let's look at the science.
You're just reading something off the Internet.
Where's that science come from?
So it really is information cause it's so easy to brainwash people nowadays.
It's so easy that media is under control.
It's way harder.
I think it's way harder to get people to believe shit now than everybody.
[inaudible] harder to control.
I think it's a brilliant job,
man.
Who's the thinking?
I mean,
just like most people think then a w nine 11 was an inside job.
Most people believe that tower seven fell because of fires because the
government told them.
I mean,
that's scary shit man.
It is.
What if nine 11 wasn't an inside job and spending all this time thinking it was,
what if it was just a bunch of incompetent people,
a bunch of people that are,
I mean,
the amount of people that had to be involved to make it against piracy,
it'd be pretty big,
right?
Yeah.
There wouldn't be more likely that has a bunch of fucking idiots running the
government,
which we've always known a true then to have this one mastermind,
stroke of genius.
No,
not at all.
When you look at,
when you look at the evidence,
I mean when,
uh,
when the nine 11 commission on down this road,
it's really simple.
It's really silly when the nine 11 commission,
we have video,
a bunch of different angles of tower seven coming down when they have that video
tower seven.
So now unquestionably one of the hardest things to kind of show.
So you just got to just like a detective,
you got to look at it like a detective.
You got,
you got,
okay.
That building came down.
So we,
the people want to know,
uh,
what happened at tower seven?
How come it looks like a demo.
It looks like exploded.
It,
it must be exploding.
That's the conspiracy theory.
What does the government say?
Nothing.
It's not in the nine 11 commission report.
They deny it.
There's no,
there's,
they don't say anything.
They don't acknowledge it.
After public pressure of wanting to know if,
uh,
that was a controlled demo or not.
We want a real investigation.
Finally,
in 2008,
they fund NIST finally came out,
a government agency comes out and he's,
and they ask them,
they go,
what?
He gives a little presentation to tower seven,
uh,
was brought down because it got too hot.
And then the,
he starts fielding questions and they said,
why didn't you guys test for explosives?
This is what this is all about.
You know what he said?
The answer was they were no witnesses that said they heard explosions.
That was his answer.
And there's uh,
any lists,
lists,
video after video after video,
after video,
firemen,
policemen,
witness after witness after witness,
after which there's all on video,
all in video,
right when it happens.
And then the bombs went off and then before that plane and then bombs were just,
and then the whole lobby was just bombs.
And then we turned around,
we were going down.
The element in the elevator blew up in this,
everyone's saying bombs.
The newscasters are saying,
wow,
they're there.
Everyone's saying bombs are going off everywhere.
Everywhere.
They took all that shit and fucking buried it.
They were saying,
there's all this,
they said,
miss,
it's on video.
They're saying,
we didn't have any.
They go,
you didn't check for explosives.
no,
we didn't check for explosive.
There was no witnesses that said they heard explosions and they was,
you just said,
that shit load.
I got to repeat it.
You know,
when you look at that,
what does that tell you?
What it tells you that they're fucking gangsters,
man.
The fucking line,
the gangsters.
It's really simple.
It's,
it's possible to gangsters.
It's also possible that they're retarded.
It's also possible that the trying to figure out a way to explain something that
the,
they just did a really shitty job of explaining the past.
There's so much in Arkansas.
There's some not an architect.
I'm not an engineer.
I don't understand how buildings,
what they need to stay up.
I don't understand what can bring them down.
When I look at that though,
it looks like a controlled demolition.
It behaves exactly the same.
I've never heard of a building that falls apart like that and just breaks apart
and free spot in free fall.
But what do I know?
I mean,
I don't know.
There was apparently massive fires all throughout the building because there was
some diesel fuel that they had in the basement,
giant diesel tanks and if those things were on fire and if the building was on
fire in some sort of a crazy way where it weakened the whole thing,
however unlikely where it uniformly,
once one part of it gave out,
it just gave any for explosives.
I understand that,
but what would disturb me about that scenario that I just just said was why
didn't someone sue for that building falling apart like I,
I would think that if that was my building and my building just caved in,
when it caught on fire,
I'd be like,
let me show you fuck heads some videos of buildings that didn't cave in because
they were up all A's just on fire.
Like every fucking corner of the building is fire and this,
this is just fire inside the building and it fell apart.
I would sue.
Yeah,
there a fucked up so much.
It's so deep.
The whole,
what do you think,
what do you think happens if you,
if you believe this,
if you believe that this is a conspiracy to take down tower seven?
Well,
this,
this is,
I want to say this.
I always thought I was,
I knew the nine 11 conspiracy quite well.
I kinda,
I kinda understood how it,
you know,
I could argue with people.
I thought it was,
I thought I was a brown belt.
Oh my God.
I watched this documentary that I don't even know if it's out yet.
Uh,
that dude who put it together,
he sent it to me.
It's five hours long,
five hours.
I watched it twice.
Or Oh my God,
it's fucking,
and it's all news clips and he,
and he's narrating through it.
He's got so
much information about how it went fucking down.
Alex Jones is like a purple belt compared to this guy.
His name is Ryan Dawson.
And the documentary is the,
um,
the empire unmasked and mass.
I kissed en masse,
the empire math,
I can't even say unmasked,
but whole Lee Shit.
It gets so fucking,
it's like watching,
it's like watching Harry,
one of the like a movie that was a book watching a movie and then watching it
three times and then going back and reading the book and you're like,
oh my God,
there's so much shit.
There's such a back story and there's all these different players and all this
evidence.
That was,
dude,
there's no way one of my buddy can watch that documentary and still think and
he's got all the evidence.
Did he breaks it all down dude,
it's,
there's so much,
there's so much.
One of my favorite things about nine 11 it never gets brought up was the press
conference had Donald Rumsfeld had the day before the Pentagon got hit.
Well he was talking about all the money that was missing was like trillions of
dollars,
right?
Like trillions of dollars they couldn't account for and then the plane slams
into the accounting department.
I mean if we are living in a movie,
this is an awesome movie.
I want to know if that is true.
Find off the plane,
hit the Pentagon,
hit the accounting department to deal with it.
That's what everybody always says.
Bill Intelligence Office,
which was investigating a lot of these,
uh,
illegal securities.
It was all,
dude,
it was according to this documentary,
the empire and mass in a nutshell,
in a nutshell,
in a nutshell.
Aliens,
Saudi Arabia there first,
first I want to say first I want to say I love this country.
I love the United States.
I just area Eddie Bravo.
Just,
I'm just scared of the government.
That's okay.
I love the country.
But we have some in every government,
people would agree that there's a criminal element in every government.
Everybody believes that there's crooks run and shit,
right?
So I'm not saying anything that crazy the,
according to this documentary,
the it's dude,
you got to go way back like a hundred years.
It's all tied together from the banana wars in the early 19 hundreds.
It's all about drug trade between sent,
controlling Central America.
First of all,
before you go into any conspiracy theories,
the one conspiracy theory that is,
uh,
that's real is Iran Contra conspiracy theory.
That's actually real.
It's out and what have you look into it.
What was it?
George Bush senior got busted him and Oliver North.
There was a few key people doing some shit that the rest of the government
didn't know about.
That's a conspiracy theory.
They were running guns and drugs through Arkansas and Iran and Israel were all
involved.
It's a big drug,
arms ring.
That's all it is.
They're all making money off it.
They've been doing,
it's the banana wars were all about the drugs they used the United States used
to with other countries go in and fucking Jack them and take their shit.
Then they realize it's easier if we just control,
the government will organize a coup and we'll pill.
I'd all guy in and we'll just take that shit.
We don't need to fight them.
So they just pulled all the military out and they've been doing that.
It's all the Nicaragua,
the Iran Contra.
They got busted,
but they've been doing it forever.
It's like a family business when that when you're at the top,
they got busted.
That's not a conspiracy theory.
They used to think it was a conspiracy theory in the 70s and everyone's like,
conspiracy theory.
There's news reports.
People are like,
it's crazy.
And then it comes out 10 years later they get busted.
Ronald Reagan says he didn't know shit.
He doesn't recall shit about vice president.
It's George Sr.
He's the ex head of the CIA.
He's running the whole fucking thing.
I know I'm,
well,
we're careful about people's attention span,
but they get busted.
You got to explain this at the top right there in the early eighties,
the shit that happened from JFK and beyond,
but JFK is connected to Iran Contra,
which is connected at nine 11.
It's all the same fucking players.
It's all the same.
It's a big old drug cartel going on.
So all the big Ah,
it's a corporate.
It's all about uh,
um,
the mob sells the drugs that the drug that the government brings in.
They always had a mob relationship.
There's always been the government running drugs using the mob to make money for
covert operations.
They've always done that shit.
That's the way they do it and all everything that's happening in the Middle
East,
that's all it is.
Do America Israel,
they want to fuck up.
They want her to fuck up.
I wreck the criminal element they want,
but United States like they need to control the poppy seed.
So it was oil,
drugs,
the same shit.
They just needed a reason to get in there.
Everybody knows that we invaded Iraq because of nine 11,
but there now we know that there's zero connection.
That was all bullshit.
We know.
That's like,
that's a fact.
That's not a conspiracy theory.
There was no weapons of mass destruction.
We just needed a reason to get in there.
Dude.
They,
there's documents that they talk about this,
these great con,
uh,
p Naca,
this group,
like how are we gonna take over and what is the best route to do?
Talking about we need a reason to get into the Middle East and control.
We need a big event.
It's on fucking paper.
Then.
Didn't never give a shit.
You ever see
the video where General General Wesley Clark starts talking about a invading
like what?
What's going to be done.
The,
the,
the timeline that's been laid out for United States to invade all these other
countries and take over or you ever seen that?
I heard something about that.
You never seen the video?
No.
What is this?
You should watch it because it's pretty fascinating.
What's it called?
General Wesley Clark.
Who's the guy who ran for president?
I think he ran for president in 2004.
Yeah.
When did he run for president?
2008 maybe.
Maybe 2008 whenever it was that he ran for president.
Um,
he was four.
He was a,
uh,
just decorated general and like a,
a patriot,
a war hero.
A guy who was like really well respected and I,
it was on Charlie rose and he laid out the government's plan.
Like the people that are you would,
you would be fascinated by that.
So I'll play it for you because for people that are listening to this and going
agenda 21 bullying,
he's explaining,
explaining like what he was privy to as a four star general or whatever it was.
And I'm in this video for people that listen to this go and this is all crazy
conspiracy talk.
When you hear a guy like Wesley Clark presidential candidate would be like very
decorated,
very well respected general saying these things like listen to what he says.
Got It.
Listen us,
about 10 days after nine 11 I went through the Pentagon and I saw secretary
Rumsfeld and and deputy searcher Wolfowitz.
I went downstairs just sail over some of the people on the Joint Staff who we've
made the decision,
we're going to war with Iraq.
This was honor band.
He said,
sir,
you got to come in.
You've got to come in and talk to me a second.
I said,
September.
we're going to war with Iraq.
Why?
Okay.
He said,
I don't know.
I guess they don't know what else to do.
So,
uh,
I said,
well,
did they find some information,
collect connecting Saddam to al Qaeda?
He said,
no,
no.
Was just,
there's nothing new that way.
They just made the decision to go to war with Iraq.
He said,
I guess it's like we don't know what to do about terrorists,
but we got a good military and we can take nail.
So I came back to see him a few weeks later and by that time we were bombing in
Afghanistan.
I said,
are we still going to war with Iraq?
And he said,
oh,
it's worse than that.
He sit down governments and he said,
I guess if the only tool you have is a hammer,
every problem reached over on his desk.
He picked up a piece of paper.
He said,
I just,
he said,
I just got this down from upstairs and saturate events office today and he said,
this is a memo that describes how we're going to take out seven countries in
five years starting with Iraq and in Syria,
Lebanon,
Libya,
Somalia,
Sudan and finishing off Iran.
Come on,
man.
Now this is the scariest part.
It is a business.
Gary leads.
Do you want to keep it going?
Had there been no oil layer,
it would be like Africa.
Nobody is threatening to intervene in Africa.
The problem is the opposite.
We keep asking for people to intervene and stop it.
And there's,
uh,
there's no question that the presence of petroleum throughout the region has
sparked great power involvement.
Whether that was the specific motivation for the coup or not,
I can't tell you,
but,
but there was definitely,
there's always been this attitude that somehow we could intervene and use force
in the region.
Boom.
Yeah.
The scariest thing is you could watch something like this and like a skeptic who
doesn't believe in any conspiracy,
you gotta watch this.
They'll,
they'll watch it and something like there've been programmed,
like they'd been hypnotized.
Like no matter what,
obey the official story.
Do you see that video that was just about to come out?
Major Smedley Butler.
Check that out.
That the,
the video that is about to come up was the,
the um,
the letter that major Smedley Butler wrote in like 1930 something and he was a,
another famous war hero who,
uh,
wrote a letter like realizing when he was leaving the military.
That war is a racket major,
general Smedley Butler and the fascist takeover.
The USA
is it put play anything
you're to roughly locate any community somewhere along that scale.
It's running all the way from democracy to despotism.
This man makes it his job and just study these things.
Avoid the comfortable idea,
but the mayor form of government kind of itself safe guide a nation against
despotism.
Okay.
50 business despotism was often a useful tool for securing foreign markets and
pursuing profits.
One of the US Marine Corps most highly decorated generals,
Smedley Darlington Butler by his own account helped pass a fly Mexico for
American oil companies,
Haiti and Cuba for National City Bank,
Nicaragua for the Brown brothers brokerage,
the Dominican Republic for Sugar Interests Honduras for us food companies in
China or standard oil
general Butler services.
We're also in demand in the United States itself.
In the 1930s as President Franklin Delano Roosevelt saw to relieve the misery of
the depression to your public enterprise and tougher regulations on corporate
exploitation and Ms Deeds,
power to you,
President Roosevelt,
the entire country's behind you,
preload with hope,
but the country was not entirely behind the populist president.
Large parts of the corporate elite despise what Roosevelt's new deal stood for.
And so in 1934 a group of conspirators sought to involve General Butler and the
trees in his plan.
I was lying to me,
what's the form and organization and veteran user that blackboard is at club,
at least you intimidate the governor,
not the corporate cabal.
I picked the wrong.
Matt Butler was fed up with being lucky call and gangster for capitalism.
All right.
Period.
Before the congressional committee,
the highest representation of the American people under subpoena your towel.
What I knew of activities which I believe might lead to an attempt to set up a
fascist dictatorship.
The upshot of that whole thing was that I was supposed to lead an organization
of 500,000 men,
which would be able to take over the functions of government.
How crazy is that?
A congressional committee ultimately found evidence of a plot to overthrow
Roosevelt.
According to Butler,
that's included represent farmers.
Some of America's top corporations,
they own the CDC be Morgan Dupont and Goodyear tire
studies.
Chairman of Goodyear tire knows to corporations to dominate government.
A Koo is no longer necessary.
Corporations have gone global.
And by going global,
the governments have lost some control of compilations regardless of whether the
cooperation can be trusted.
Oh,
cannot be trusted.
Governments today do not have over the complications,
the power that they had and the leverage that they had 50 or 60 years ago.
That's the force of major change.
So of good governance have become powerless compared to where they were before.
Capitalism today to the towering heights and has displaced politics and
politicians as the new high priests and raining all the guards.
So if our systems,
so capitalism and its principal protagonists and players,
corporate CEOs have been accorded unusual power and access.
It was just not to deny the significance of government and politicians,
but these are the new high priests.
Okay,
well that's all.
Uh,
that's pretty much proven what you're saying.
I mean that when you look at that,
you look at Iran Contra and,
or at least this is how this is,
the scariest part is,
you know,
certain amount of people can be hypnotized.
You know you've got a hypnotist show,
the guy before the show starts,
he does a couple of tests and he goes,
I got that idiot and I got that motherfucker all you other sit down.
He knows he could figure it out.
Right.
It's not a conspiracy theory.
Right,
right.
He took,
what is it?
That's,
that's pretty crazy that he knows that there's a few people that he gets
hypnotized and there's others that you can't.
So then he makes them do weird shit.
And people have been,
is hypnotism Rio,
do Pete,
can people be hypnotized and yes,
it can.
They,
is it real that you can hypnotize someone,
wake them up.
They appear to be woken up and when they hear you say a certain word,
they react a certain way.
Is that real or is that,
that's real.
That real with some people if,
uh,
if they,
they get good enough at it.
I've seen documentaries,
but maybe they were hoaxes.
I don't know.
I don't know if they're real.
I'm pretty sure.
Well,
I've been hypnotized and hypnotism is real.
Okay.
Definitely.
What Israel,
well,
it's not,
at least with me.
What what the guy was trying to do was not what I think would be done if someone
was trying to get you to do something like that.
But if it's,
if is it possible to hypnotize someone in their own whatever way,
whatever way works,
and tell them when you wake up,
when I hear,
when you hear the bell,
you are going to react a certain way or you're going to think a certain way and
so that person could be totally awake at work and then you could say something
and they react a certain way that I'm sure if it appears
that,
I think that's,
that's like just give it a lot of time from the hypnosis event.
Oh No,
not at work,
but I'm not,
I'm not,
I don't know why I said at work,
but I'm just saying if it work,
who knows?
Maybe it's supposed to wear off after five minutes or 10 minute.
When does it,
when you change states,
if you're in a state of anger is state of depression are saying there's like a
state that you achieve when you get hypnotized.
Okay.
Even though you're aware of it,
you're awake.
Let me just explain what it feels like.
It felt like,
like all,
it's almost like I was on drugs like a,
I went to some weird,
like a k hole or something like that.
Like it was a very strange,
it felt very almost not,
I want to,
I want to say out of body,
but inner body.
But I was awake,
I was never asleep.
But like if anything crazy happened,
like an alarm went off or I would've got right up,
like I would have been fine.
But in that state,
like someone can talk you into that state and you put yourself,
you willingly allow yourself to get into that state.
That's for me in this situation,
if it was a different situation and it was a more gullible person or more easily
led person,
and then the,
the hypnosis,
a professional was like more into doing that more into hypnosis professionals,
not hypnotist.
Okay.
If that guy was,
I'm more into getting you to remember a certain noise or certain sound and when
you heard that sound,
you're gonna associate with something.
Yeah,
I think that's possible.
Okay,
so let's assume that's real and it probably is.
It might be all hoaxes,
but I've seen documentaries.
I don't know for sure it's a documentary.
I don't think it is a hoax.
This assume it's real.
If that's real then that then you can say that a certain percent of the
population
can be hypnotized.
Right?
Just like that.
Not everybody,
but a certain,
what is that percentage?
Let's just say that just guests and say what if it's 30% of the population has
hitting the hypnotism abilities?
Is might be everyone if you allow yourself to be,
yes,
it might be everyone.
Exactly.
It might be,
let's just say 30% let's say 60 40 whatever.
Then that if those documentaries that were talking about it,
it's true.
If it is real that you could do that,
then can you
trigger something?
The people that can be hypnotized,
like 30% of them.
Can you a program,
something on TV,
whether it's in the news or whatever,
something.
Are they doing something to handle those people and get them to only believe in
what they see on TV?
You don't have to do it like that.
You don't have to do it with it.
With that one possible.
Yeah.
But you wouldn't do it that way.
No,
because you'd have to sit down with those people and actually hypnotize them.
It'd get them into that state.
You have to know what kind of state they're in when you're bringing these
suggestions into their mind.
Sometimes hypnotize Watson narco highs.
Fuck yeah,
but that's different.
I don't think the government is trying to hit me time.
You're not,
you don't believe that the government government's trying to hypnotize you
through Netflix?
Probably.
I believe
that.
I don't think Netflix is Inca.
Who?
To the government that meetings with them.
They seem like normal people.
Um,
but my point is,
this is just my wild conspiracy theory that,
I mean an answer,
an attempt to answer the question,
why you can show someone film like that.
Like what you just him like that and there's five hours of shit like that.
The empire and mass is five hours and shit like that.
Okay.
What?
People can see it,
right?
They can see the build tower seven go boom.
But they're going to believe the government.
I look,
I keep saying it's one of those towers
looks to me like an implosion.
It looks to me like a demo,
Alicia,
but I don't know shit.
I don't know shit.
You know there's two their roles in giant fire inside that building,
the cost of building the fail and it collapsed like that.
And I'm talking all this crazy shit.
I know they blew it up.
I know they use bombs then I'm an idiot.
And so if I'm saying I know one way or the other,
it's kind of crazy.
I can't,
you can't really say it.
I don't have enough information.
But you've got to have,
based on what you see your opinion based on one for sure.
That's not my opinion.
My opinion is it looks like a controlled demolition.
Yeah.
Now if you see a submission,
okay,
and you know it's a dog shit submission and the guy taps out,
you go,
well that guy quit.
Well you'll know that guy quit because you'll know that that's not a good
submission because you're an expert in submissions.
When I see a building collapse like that,
I'll say,
yeah,
it looks like a controlled demolition because that's what it looks like,
but that doesn't mean it's a controlled demolition.
You could easily have been a crazy fire that caused a catastrophic failure of
the structure of that building.
And I don't know Jack Shit about structures of bill,
of course.
No,
I can't say that.
Nobody's saying that you do and no one is saying that you,
based on what you're,
like a juror isn't an expert in all this forensics.
You're going on what the experts say.
You're not going on.
Jurors not going to go,
well,
I don't know if he killed him.
I wasn't actually there.
So I don't know.
There's all this evidence,
the Jurassic based on the evidence,
you have to,
you know,
it's,
it's okay to say,
uh,
based on all the gangster shit that's going on.
They don't say shit for seven years.
A detective would go later.
Okay,
let's get away from that.
Here's what's interesting about that building.
Here's one of the things that makes this,
this theory more fascinating,
and this is a fact.
They had offices inside that building of the NSA.
I think it was the CIO who find out what offices were inside tower seven cause
it was a crazy building.
It wasn't just like a regular building.
That building had some really nutty shit stored in it.
Some crazy information in offices like w it was,
it wasn't like,
oh my God,
they,
they crushed the prudential building.
We lost all this insurance policy numbers and you know,
data.
Nope.
No,
it wasn't that.
it was way nuttier than that.
It was,
it was like really intense foreign policy shit.
Intense financial shit.
It was like there's some crazy offices inside there.
When you got there,
Jamie,
here we go.
Like look at,
look at what was in building
seven.
This is fucking fascinating.
Can you imagine Simon Smith and Barney.
Okay.
Uh,
which is a financial company,
Internal Revenue Service,
regional council,
US Secret Service,
American Express Bank,
International Standard Chartered Bank,
uh,
provident financial market management.
Um,
Hartford Insurance Group,
first date management group,
Federal Loan Bank,
a lot of banks.
But in a,
I see securities securities and Exchange Commission.
That's when it gets really crazy security and exchange commissions like that's
the fucking that,
I mean that's,
that's the mother lode of money right there.
New York City office of emergency management.
What would it,
what would a decent detective think based on all this?
Would it go?
No,
they couldn't do.
He would look at that and you'd go,
wow,
it's convenient at that building collapsed because it seems like there's a lot
of fucking tenants in there that probably had a lot of crazy information.
The Secret Service Security Exchange Commission and the office of emergency
management.
That's a,
that's a lot of like and then all those banks.
It's just high level feelings.
Really important shit.
High level gangster.
She knows.
I thought it was the CIA.
I thought the CIA was in there as well.
A small office of the Cin is was Eddie Bravo conspiracy theorist.
He knows I'm just a blue belt competitor ride dos.
Well there's a lot of people have spent their whole life looking at it.
If it is what we said or what I said,
rather a catastrophic failure of a structure based on bill.
If it is,
if it that is what a convenient building to collapse.
Like it seems like those offices would have a lot of really crazy shit in them
and if a decent detective found out that oh it looks like to over 2000
architects risking their license,
risking that gorilla credibility is going to go against the government.
Right,
right,
right.
But
the truth is that what you talking about those day they have the balls to do
what everyone else is like.
They don't want,
most people don't want any trouble.
I want to know is how many architects disagree with them and who's the better
architectures.
The video show me that but that's what I don't know.
I don't have the balls obvious.
This is,
we're talking about obvious shit.
I know you have to stay on the fence.
I know.
I know that dot.
Jude is not,
I have to,
I stay on the fence cause this is how I try to think.
I try to,
I try to not to look at the evidence,
the evidence.
I'm looking at it like some seven years I taught it would come out with a report
and then they don't test for explosives.
I thought that when we were looking at that a report,
I thought we're going to see the CIA in there.
It's less impressive with uh,
what we,
what we did have in there.
I don't know if they would be,
that's not every rate.
It might very well could be.
I don't know if they would rig a building like that with explosives when they
were building it in the possibility that something went wrong and they had to
destroy evidence.
No,
that is no,
but there could be positive and said that,
and you're,
you're,
you can't even bring that up because no one that has never been brought up.
But wait a minute.
That's what happened.
If the building exploded,
okay,
if you did,
if you do
believe that the building was a controlled demolition,
then someone rigged it.
So the idea is if they knew that these people are going to be in this building,
they knew this building was going to be a high seek,
a high security building.
They could have rigged it with explosives when they were constructing it to make
sure that in event the building was taken.
Why he said that didn't happen because when did it get detonated?
When did it get,
when did it get fit?
But when it did get fitted with those explosives were just six weeks.
That's what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is there are,
there's,
it's not my idea either.
This many people that are speculating that when the building was actually
constructed,
they constructed it with this possibility.
They made it.
Why you say,
no,
no.
Why do you say no?
When you look at the whole story,
I'm only bringing up tower seven,
but there's a million pieces to the store.
When you put all the pieces together,
you're like,
well,
it's just one part of building.
Why do you,
why are you convinced that that's how the building,
I brought it out.
What does it say?
The Department of Defense is Central Intelligence Agency.
Okay.
Yeah.
They shared the 25th for the IRS.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's it.
[inaudible] hold on.
This is,
we're just reading this,
the facts.
So the Department of Defense and the Central Intelligence Agency were there on
the 25th for,
with the IRS floors,
46 three 47 where mechanical floors as were the bottom floors and part of the
seventh floor.
Okay.
And that could all be bullshit.
That who knows,
that could just be someone just fucking around.
That's Wikipedia,
Bro Lock.
Where did that come?
That is locked down and tight.
But why would you think that it's an impossible for them to rig the building
with explicitly construct?
It's impossible because they didn't say anything for seven years after public
pressure that we're forced to have put a scientist out there in front of these
reporters to finally give a reason.
And they said it was because of fires they didn't,
I understand.
And the gas,
why didn't you acts Chet for explosives?
You just,
this is what it was all of us three times to get it.
I got to get it.
But that's not,
that doesn't mean it's impossible.
I'm just looking at the evidence,
but that's not even the evidence.
It doesn't mean that it's impossible.
If,
if if was a controlled demolition,
let's get crazy and alien could have blew it up.
That's not impossible.
Let's say it.
Let's look at it and say it controlled demolition.
Let's say it looks like in controlled demolition.
Let's assume it is.
How did the,
how did the bombs get into the building?
How did they put him in?
Why is it impossible?
If you look into,
if you wait,
you ask him a question.
Why is it impossible that they put those bombs in it when they were building it
in the case or when the secret service took over or when whoever was made the
tenant,
maybe they installed the bombs to make sure in an event that something happened.
Like in 96 I believe it was 96 the World Trade Center towers,
they blew them up in the basement.
Remember they had a car bomb that went off in the base when they thought they
were gonna take the tower down.
If these people thought that put this building in place or that took over this
building,
the CIA,
the NSA,
whoever the fuck it was,
if they knew that they had some really important secure information there,
it's very possible.
Could have said,
okay,
in the event that someone does blow up the World Trade Center,
like in [inaudible] 96 because it's already happened before and a catastrophic
failure we can dump,
we can demolish this building a,
if you're a view wanted,
if you want us,
uh,
lean towards that theory,
that's fine too.
I'm not trying to lean in towards anything,
but why are you saying that?
That's impossible.
Anything's possible.
I wasn't there.
You weren't there,
but we're going based on what we know Jurors d w like,
like if this was the jury finding,
we're not looking for God's truth.
We're looking like a jury,
like a detective.
How would they handle the truth?
You know what I mean?
If everybody was legit,
you got to look at it like that.
What do you think happened if you think it was a controlled demolition?
How do you think mom's got in the building?
It's so deep.
It's so deep and so long.
Like I said,
you put all of that nine 11 information.
Forget about the Pentagon.
This five hour documentary has nothing to do with the Pentagon.
That's like so much info.
Just like that video you showed five hours of that crushing evidence.
You look at that as a Jew or as a detective,
you're like,
of course it was an inside job.
He in that documentary,
they lay out the countries that have always done shit like this.
They've always done it that day.
They got busted in Iran contract.
But let's,
let's knock it off course here.
I want to,
I still want to find out you thinking on the building seven,
cause you're convinced the building seven one's a demolition,
right?
As a juror.
It's a demolition based on all the testimony.
How do you think they set it up for demolition?
Well,
uh,
there,
there's evidence if you watching this documentary just so much information,
but there's evidence of,
of them constantly doing work and fake ass workers working on the elevator
shafts.
There's all this evidence of that.
They can,
they,
it's so deep.
I don't want to,
I don't remember the names of the guys are all these people that were working
there.
They just set that building up to blow up.
Yeah.
They took time and they just had fake fake,
uh,
the,
it's a fact that the elevator was always broken and there was always people like
the month before,
there's all these fake passes and there's a lot of evidence is five hours,
you're going to go,
shit,
there's report is kind of,
there's all the bravo.
Yeah.
But you know what?
I'm so obsessed with those details.
I don't know why,
but I,
we're living in a world post nine 11.
That's,
we're living in a crazy world where people are fucking dying in the Middle East
and getting blown up and getting murdered and kids and stuff like that that's
going on.
I just can't,
I need to find out why they're doing like,
what's going on.
I just,
I'm obsessed with,
well,
how is this racket?
How do they operate?
I want to know the truth.
And when you know the truth,
it's just like,
fuck.
You just want to tell as many people as possible.
We're this,
look,
George Bush,
a singer gets busted Nash on national TV,
uh,
with the Iran Contra,
situation.
He becomes president after that and then he's running all his shit and all this
drugs in his arms through Arkansas with an unknown governor who Bill Clinton,
who's letting it happen.
And then he becomes President George Bush as a detective.
I don't know the truth.
I wasn't there.
I don't know what the relationship looks like.
I'm like,
that's a,
that's a fucking,
that's some gangster shit going on right there.
And they're just playing with the public and all the,
the dumb motherfuckers who believed that there's,
you know,
this Republican Democrat,
a battle going on,
you know,
that's,
it's,
it's a fascinating and frustrating at the same time and very scary that man,
we're living with people there that just follow the official story and whatever
they say,
that's the truth and all the other shit that's not that this stuff,
that's crazy when they,
a lot of people that do really love to bar the official store and they love to
argue it.
They love to argue the official story.
Yeah.
The scary thing is Pete,
the people,
when you ask anybody,
they'll say,
yeah,
the government's fucked.
Fucked up.
Yeah.
The government,
you can't trust the government.
Everybody would say that.
Everyone,
everyone,
no one's ever,
no one's ever said,
you can totally trust the government.
I trust the government.
No one ever says that ever.
They,
oh,
everyone says I fuck the government bunch of crooks.
But when when they get busted and there's all this evidence and all shake gone
to shit going down and it's so crystal clear.
Can you imagine if those,
the video of not of tower seven was not available until 10 years later?
No,
that would be the craziest fucking a conspiracy theory that nobody would get
behind.
Nobody would waste their time.
That building goes down.
There's no video of it.
There's going to be people that were there.
It's like,
dude,
it's a crazy bill.
Some tower seven just fell down like,
like,
like it was controlled demo.
People call you crazy mother.
Fuck,
where's the video?
Where's the video?
That's all they would know.
Didn't say what happened with the Kennedy assassination.
Exactly.
That was 10 years later.
So with,
can you imagine if there was no video because of all the angles that came out
right away.
Right away.
We had all that footage.
It's almost like it like that was good for the people that were behind this.
Like it was beautiful cause you could see that on youtube and has millions of
views,
but people will go,
well the government said it was fires,
so I believe it's fires.
Hmm.
You know,
I mean you're watching it,
you're watching it go down a bunch of different angles.
But I'm going to go with the government on this one government per 200 that
scary.
That kind of mentality is what I'm scared of.
I'm scared of the conspiracy theories.
That shit,
I hate this fucking joint.
You here's killing my brain.
I've got to go to Australia,
Bro.
I can't handle it now.
Crazy shit man.
Maybe I,
maybe I should just say shut the fuck up about it and just close my fucking eyes
just looked straight.
Sometimes I think about that.
You know,
I wonder,
I wonder how long if,
if there really is some crazy global cabal going on.
It's ripping off the world how much longer they,
and they keep going with this and this these days of Edward Snowden.
You know what?
There's,
there's hope,
information leaks when,
when you find out exactly how the racket and works,
the global racket works,
when you look into it with an open mind.
And I mean
we just went right back into it.
We're going to get out of it.
I didn't know what I was going to say.
Me.
What were we even talking about?
Global Cabal.
Look how it works.
If you look at how it works,
man,
I totally forgot.
I taught global Kabbalah.
We'll just figure this out.
Global Cobol and what else?
I'm going to go with tower seven,
chem trail,
black helicopter,
CIA,
George Bush.
I remember,
I remember he seals
when you look at it,
how it all goes down and bit by bit how it all goes down.
It's like fucking nuts.
It's nuts.
And I think there's no way we could ever,
uh,
regain control of the media because that's where all the power is.
It all comes down to the media.
Who controls that shit?
And,
uh,
when you do we ever have control,
we got to go to alternative media for the truth.
And,
but then no one believes that.
Everyone believes that the shit that the government gives us,
the PR pro fucking propaganda machine from Pentagon.
Everyone believes that they don't believe the alternative media because,
Oh,
you know what?
It looks like it was low budget.
Cause look at the kind of film and the lighting they use.
It doesn't,
I don't believe that that looks like they're in the garage.
I want to believe this shit on Fox.
That's how people think.
They might not say that,
but that's what's going on because that's what people believe.
Most of people think,
but as the news as a shittier and Shittier job of covering events in detail,
I think people are leaning more and more towards alternative sources.
Yes.
It's like the Guardian when they released all those Ed Snowden documents that
they weren't the only ones who were offered that.
Yeah.
It's just they got lucky.
They found a guy in Glenn Greenwald wanting to put his balls out there and do it
and then they go after whistle blowers.
Man.
John Stott
well is a former CIA agent,
wrote a couple books,
CIA to control the royalties of his books because you can't be talking about
this stuff,
so he's not making money off the puts.
The CIS,
they just took control of his shed.
It's John Stockwell.
He was a CIA agent for 13 years.
Most of the people in the CIA,
they come in to fight communism.
They're trying to help the world.
They're trying to help the United States.
It's the criminal element.
There's a few key players.
The guys with all the power at the top,
the craziest guys at the top and a lot of guys in the sea.
I have no idea.
They don't tell anyone.
Everybody.
I think it's like what you were saying earlier that we were talking about how in
the 1980s and whatever before the Internet there was only a few different
programs to everybody was on these channels,
but I think in this day and age there's so much information out there.
There's so much stuff to listen to it so much stuff to watch,
so much stuff to pay attention to.
It's just overwhelming that when something happens,
even if it's a big deal,
it's gone a couple of days,
just some new shit coming down the pipe.
University in Missouri,
they're having a fucking hunger strike.
Oh,
that lady,
she pushed that kid and she called for muscle.
Like the,
there's a new thing every God damn day.
You know,
a few days ago the Pentagon got busted with a gas station that cost $43 million
to build.
And everyone is like,
why is the gas station that part of the world is normally full of between 200
and $500,000 to build a gas station 43 million.
And they're like,
it just is.
It's fucking expensive.
I mean,
even the latest word out there,
I,
Donald Rumsfeld,
the day nine 11 set,
oh yeah,
we have two point $3 trillion missing.
It's ridiculous,
right?
It just says we don't know where it's at,
but it's gone.
So they had to make a fucking Pentagon briefing that a data tell the world,
listen,
we lost two point 3 trillion.
The number 10.
Yeah.
That was September 10th and the next day,
uh,
that office in the Pentagon is looking into.
It blows up.
But anyways,
as a,
as a juror,
I'm,
I'm like gangsters.
Gangster Shit's going on right here.
Did I don't have to.
I'm not fucking a,
I'm,
I'm a grown ass man.
I know how gangsters they are.
I'm like,
that's dude.
It's obvious.
Yes.
Right.
So,
but the hope you,
you think there's no hope because they control the media.
They got it.
But what shows me hope is what's happening with hemp and marijuana.
The Resurgens taken a schedule,
one drug,
a schedule one drug,
and making it legal that,
that several states,
including Washington DC,
which is crazy.
It's more and more and more it's becoming legal.
So that shows that the federal government doesn't,
they still schedule it.
One,
they,
they didn't want this.
But that shows that the people actually ultimately,
if the people all can get together,
they do have all the power that people do have the power,
because we still remember that from the constitution.
That's one thing we remember.
We,
I don't remember a fucking amendments and all that,
but I go,
I know we have the power and you guys supposed to be working for us right now.
It's not like that and it's fucked up.
But we know we're supposed to have the power.
And when we learned that and we learned how powerful we are,
we took a schedule,
one drug that was demonized,
that was persecuted.
It wasn't just left by itself.
They went after the psyche of the nation on globally.
Really not just nationally.
That was real.
That's not a conspiracy theory.
The reefer mapper Maddis propaganda,
that some evil shit.
So when people tell me,
Oh,
do you know there's parts of the government that do this?
I don't need fucking evidence.
You could tell him anything.
I'm like,
it's probably true.
And if it's not true,
who gives a fuck anyways,
but I believe it.
You're talking about criminals is a criminal activity and does it seem like,
oh,
you can make money that way.
Whatever you're telling me,
I see where the money comes from.
If I don't see where the money comes from,
Michael,
maybe it's bullshit.
But if you could see how they could make money,
they probably do it.
Cause if you just thought of it,
they probably thought of it to the run and everything.
So,
um,
but there's hope,
there's hope and my shit that people do have the fucking power box.
We can make a different position.
Their position when they,
they can
lock people up when they're going to intimidate people.
The threat of locking people up for something as silly as marijuana.
I mean people will say,
well that's,
you know,
it's not even an important point.
It's under.
I remember when Obama said there was a,
there was some sort of,
uh,
of writing on the Internet.
Like what should,
what should they talk about?
And I forget what speech he was given.
What would a town hall,
what was the number one question?
And he's like,
the number one question was legalization of marijuana.
And he was like,
[inaudible] what that says about the people that are calling in and haul,
you know,
he jokes around about it.
Like it's not,
it's not a,
you know,
a serious topic.
But of course it's serious topic because marijuana by itself,
whether you pot or don't like pot,
it's not about that.
It's about freedom and it's a serious topic.
When you have a subject like marijuana,
which all these people enjoy and there's no reason why it should be illegal and
yet it's still illegal.
That's not freedom.
See,
if marijuana made people's fucking brains melt and made your Dick fall off and
you know,
made people just start running out into traffic,
there would be a reason why someone would say,
hey,
we got to spend a lot of money to stop this because it's going to destroy our
youth,
ruin our children,
just devastate our society.
Since that evidence doesn't exist,
it doesn't make any sense.
So if someone is still arresting people when there's no evidence that they
should be,
that's when shit gets scary.
That's scary.
That's a freedom issue because they're letting you know they can just lock you
in a cage.
We have a difference of opinion.
I'm not even willing to look at scientific evidence.
I don't care about scientific evidence.
I care about what's written on this piece of paper.
And this piece of paper says,
if you're stuck,
if you have a certain amount of these plants,
I can put you in a cage and I can make money off of you being in that fucking
cage.
That is a freedom issue.
It has nothing to do with marijuana itself or you and I are obviously marijuana
advocates and were marijuana enthusiasts and we're known for having beliefs that
marijuana is not just a,
it's not just a fun thing,
but it's a very important thing for creativity.
It's like a turbocharger for creativity.
Absolutely,
and it doesn't get recognized for what it is because it's been demonized and so
it's not about whether or not you should start doing it or other people should
start having our our opinions and and changing your mind on it.
It's about recognizing why we have these opinions in the first place because
they're not based on fact at all.
These are 1930s propaganda ideas that were at the time fucking tsunamis,
right?
Tsunamis of information back when there was so few portals,
they put a movie like reefer madness out.
William Randolph Hearst is the guy running the newspaper is,
he's got all these stories he's printing about Mexicans and black people raping
white people.
When those were the only fucking voices on the horizon,
people freaked out about any kind of information like that.
That was all that was available.
It wasn't like that.
And then you'd go online and Mike Tyson fucked a tiger.
What?
You know,
or you know Dan Ariens billion dollars playing poker.
What do you suppose they went after marijuana and are just a demonic way?
Well,
I think it was gone after in a very calculated way by a guy who went after a lot
of things like that.
William brand offers stand to profit from marijuana being illegal,
remaining illegal.
He,
in fact,
they named it marijuana for people don't even know the name.
Marijuana referred to a wild Mexican tobacco and it had nothing to do with
cannabis.
Cannabis was hemp and everybody knew that and they knew that as a textile and as
a commodity,
it was extremely valuable for the American people,
for people don't know.
There was actually a documentary that Jack Hara found and it was a big deal that
he found it because he had known about this and people denied its existence.
And then he found this documentary hemp for victory and it was made during World
War Two after hamp was essentially made,
but they wanted
him to use for sales.
They used for canvas is all made with hemp.
All the,
the great paintings like the Mona Lisa that she has painted on canvas,
which comes from cannabis,
I mean is it is a commonly used plant throughout human history.
Thousands of years of use,
all like intercepted by a propaganda campaign.
This propaganda campaign by one guy and a bunch of other people that conspired
with as well,
where there's two factions of it.
One guy wanted to do put up movies.
I,
William Randolph paid for that,
but he also owned Hearst publications.
He,
oh,
he owned the newspapers.
So he printed these wild stories of white women getting raped by people smoking
marijuana.
He owned hundreds of like he owned,
not just newspaper,
but he owned hundreds of thousands of acres of trees and he used those trees and
made paper out of them.
He own paper mills.
If camp became the new billion dollar crop as it was predicted on the cover of
Popular Science magazine,
if that happened,
we end brand off hers would,
I mean he would have been fucked.
He would have to spend millions of dollars converting his newspapers to hemp
paper.
So he was like,
fuck it,
I'll just write evil shit about marijuana.
I'll just call it marijuana.
So wasn't even about going after the drug.
It was about going after the what the fibers of the plant do.
That's a conspiracy theory right there it is.
And can you imagine that was all during the 30s and forties.
He imagined that they had to be some people that were thought of as some tinfoil
hat wearing conspiracy theorists that are saying that we is actually not,
doesn't make you do all these crazy things that they're putting in the movies.
And with all this reformat and propaganda,
there's people,
those people must have been a,
they looked so goddamn crazy,
but even today people try to debunk this.
I've,
I've people have said that to me and they sent me to a website,
dude,
that's been debunked.
Sorry,
my bunk that,
that William Randolph Hearst a,
it had set up marijuana for and worked with.
Um,
what was the guy's name?
Harry Harry Anslinger ads.
But it's an,
that hasn't been debunked.
Not only,
it hasn't not been debunked.
We am runoff.
Hearse was a notable cont.
Like everybody knew he was a con.
Orson Welles made a movie about it.
What a conti was back.
Who's protecting fucking William Randolph Hearst.
They just,
it's the same mentality.
It's the same mentality we're talking to people is the same,
I believe 100% of exactly 100% he Harvey Oswald acted Oh hundred percent hundred
percent I'm 100% for 100% the Lee Harvey Oswald was going with it.
They would never lie.
Well people,
you know,
it's,
it's hard because some people automatically gravitate towards conspiracies.
Some people automatically gravitate towards when they're criminals towards the
official story.
But I think a lot of times the stories,
the reality somewhere in the middle,
and it's,
it's hard to find the reality depending on the conspiracy theory.
You can't say that about it.
That's true.
Nine 11 there's so,
there's so much shit.
And like I said,
people think however crazy they think it is.
Iran Contra was justice craze.
Everyone thought that was real and it got busted.
They got the balls to,
we ran our first thing.
Here's why.
It really can't be totally debunked.
First of all,
we don't really know.
We weren't there.
So it's,
it's,
it's very difficult to prove and it's very difficult to dip disproof.
But one thing we do know,
he definitely did print stories about this drug that everyone was terrified off.
Yeah,
he definitely did contribute to the making of reefer madness.
I'm almost positive of that.
Okay.
Find Out William Randolph first had anything to do with the funding of the movie
reefer madness.
We need a memo where he all okays that story.
Yeah,
he signed off on it.
But here's the other,
the other aspect of it that we even talk about this,
the timing of this is right after prohibition ended,
so prohibition was a boon to law enforcement.
They were constantly working,
they were arresting people,
locking people up,
and then on top of that,
organized crime emerges in a huge way.
I mean,
that's where Al Capone got all his money.
That's where the Kennedy's got their fucking money.
Also,
it's all from run and booze,
man.
So there's all these people that are illegally run in booze and then making
crazy money and they wind up in positions of power and even wind up having their
fucking children's become president.
That's the real story of the United States is at Kennedy's fucking parents were
drug runners.
They're drug was just a liquid drug.
It's just as just the same as running coke,
just the same as,
as grown weed right now today.
Not Criminals.
It's all,
and JFK and his brother Robert,
they,
something turned them and they decided they're going to try and save the world,
maybe terming trust them because one thing's for sure,
he was an extreme.
He was like Bill Clinton when it came to girls.
They thought they had him in the bag.
They thought he wouldn't,
he totally just stay in line and uh,
they had to get rid of him.
Everybody.
So they,
that's interesting.
So they'd probably like have a guide like that to get them in the office and go
listen to,
we know you're a freak.
Okay.
Fuck as many as you want.
We'll,
we'll keep,
we'll keep you protected or you know,
Shit's going to get ugly sign a couple bills,
a little trade agreement.
Big Deal.
We're going to up in the Congo side.
Just you could do it.
A little trade agreement with Mexico and all that,
but it's very,
who knows?
It's,
it's very intriguing when you start looking at possibilities like that because
it comes from a criminal family.
So you know,
it's very obvious.
They're all gangsters.
He,
they,
they turn,
they tried to change the world and then they had to get rid of them.
It's just like,
it's like,
you know,
so you've got an Easter one on one and then you've got the gangsters through the
police officers who are arresting people for Booze.
Okay.
Because let's be honest,
it's not the cops that are the gangsters,
but the people that are telling the cops where to go for sure gangsters.
Why are they telling him?
Why is it out in the first place?
Like,
who the fuck?
Who says you can't have whiskey?
Were what kind of bitches are we were supposed to be America.
Someone's gonna come along and say,
you can have a drink.
How about fuck you?
That doesn't make any sense.
You can't drink.
So I'm supposed to just live my life by your fucking wacky rules.
I'd like drinking is fun.
It's so much fun.
It should be illegal.
It should be.
I'd be all for it.
Making it illegal.
It'd be cool.
Drink it like uh,
uh,
back in the twenties or thirties,
an organized crime would be even bigger,
man.
Let's shift becomes dangerous.
Look,
they mean Jack on the corner.
Here's proof example.
Jack Daniels had been around forever,
right?
They sell whiskey super popular everywhere.
I drink Jack Daniels on a regular basis,
right?
That companies not evil,
not killing anybody.
Jack Daniels is in fucking gun people down the street.
Jack Daniels isn't taken over.
New Territory's.
Jack Daniels is in fucking Berlin and holes underneath prisons and digging
people out at home would,
but the corporation that owns Jack Daniels,
probably,
I don't know if the corporation is even Jack Daniels itself.
It might just be Jack Daniels distillery.
I don't know that shit over.
Come on cares.
Who Cares?
My point is that Jack Daniels isn't an evil company.
They can make money,
but if you can make money doing shit like that,
then there's less of a,
a criminal element to it.
It's a safe company.
There's a lot of bad shit they gets done by people were drunk on Jack Daniels
for sure,
but at Jack Daniel's,
the company is not like Al Capone.
That's my point.
It's like when you let the,
let companies sell things legally,
you get the tax benefit from it and the companies aren't filled with criminals
because the only people that are willing to run heroin are going to be crazy
fuckers like that guy from breaking bad.
That's going to be,
the people are going to be running heroin.
They're going to be out of their fucking mind.
Those are the people that you're going to get,
but if it was legal,
you're going to get Bill Gates,
you know?
I mean,
if it's legal,
it fucking how many rock stars have their own whiskey or Tequila or some shit
like that.
There's a bunch of those guys.
So rappers,
they would have their own tequila or something.
Like everybody's got their own shit,
like it's okay,
they're legal drug dealers,
but as long as you're making money,
legally paying taxes,
the whole thing,
it's across.
It's above board.
No one cares.
It's like it's proof positive that drugs should be legal because alcohol was one
of the fucking worst.
The one of the worst for your body.
Worse than cocaine.
Most likely we're the traffic accidents.
Are Their cars out there that won't turn off?
Yes,
the driver's drunk.
My friend had one.
Wow.
My friend in Colorado had one.
He uh,
he got a [inaudible].
He's a buddy of mine from New York.
Moved to Colorado or is that why he had it?
Use it for work.
He got a Dui.
It's not,
the car is not unique.
It's a setup on the ignition.
They have a thing built into the ignition and the ignition will will not start
unless he blows a,
he has to blow a blood alcohol content that it has to wait a few minutes and it
won't.
It won't fire up for him if he's drunk.
That's brilliant.
Yeah,
it should be mandatory.
It's a good idea,
but it's not,
it's not convenient.
At least his wasn't.
His says it takes a few minutes and I'm like,
dude,
that's got to suck in the snow because it's Colorado.
I mean he lives in Denver.
This is drunk driving schools.
They had to,
they don't want that to Scott.
Their lobbying against it.
They're holding it back.
They probably would have had them a long time ago,
but the drunk driving topless schools,
they all got together.
Well,
what's going to save that is he's fucking Google cars and these like the Tesla
that can drive itself,
that's going to save all that.
How does that work?
They work on sensors.
They already work on centers like it's,
it's a fairly common now that your car will know when you're going across lines
now,
have you ever noticed that?
Like A,
there's a lot of cars like,
um,
I had an infinity.
It did.
It was sort of drawing selves.
No,
but it lets you know.
No.
If you're crossing a line,
it keeps you like Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Cadillac has one.
It's weird,
man.
They'd,
if you've seen those new Cadillac escalades dude,
those things are dope.
I rent one of those everywhere I go.
I love those things.
I love,
first of all,
I love him because I'm an old Italian man.
Hello?
It's a fuck.
Could Cadillac a good,
uh,
they're probably,
they're probably in the high sixties,
maybe in the 70s of thousand dollars.
They're not cheap,
but they're not cheaply made either.
They're fucking bad ass.
I rent them all the time.
I love them.
They're so smooth to do.
They have this like magnetic ride control suspension,
so like just floats over everything.
You get this great view of every,
everything.
Every time I'm in one,
I'm like,
why don't I drive one of these every day?
But they have this thing in the seat where if you get close to the edge,
it vibrates on your thigh,
on your left thigh.
So like if you're getting close to the edge of the lines,
like where the lines are,
it lets you know,
hey,
hey bitch,
get over here.
It's really weird.
It's real weird if you're backing up,
like give you live a little vibrate if you get too close to things.
So it's not just looking,
you're not just seeing it in a camera or hearing it and beeps that like get
clean.
You don't have,
they have those.
And some BMWs,
they have that BBB BBB closer.
You get to think,
hey bet you're gonna hit the fucking day.
Um,
not only does a Cadillac do that,
but it vibrates your seat.
It lets you know like where it is.
Like if you're about to hit something on the right hand side,
your right thigh will start vibrating.
It's really weird.
It's fucking trippy.
Hmm.
I don't remember what my point was.
What kind of my car.
Oh,
so that's how the,
they use some sort of cameras to see those lanes.
So they know when you're out of lanes they cause even if the road curves,
they know,
they know if you keep going straight and the road curves,
bitch,
what the fuck are you doing?
And they also have this thing called,
um,
it's a,
it's,
you know how you have cruise control like regular cruise control.
This is a laser,
a laser distance detecting cruise control.
So like say if your car,
that's pretty common now too.
If your car is ahead of mine and I set my cruise control for 65 miles an hour,
if you slow down,
my car slows down to,
if you speed up my car speeds up.
I don't have to touch shit.
You just put your hands on the steering wheel.
Oh,
it slows down for you.
It speeds up for you.
You know,
anybody who buys a car like that,
it's going to sign a fucking stock away versus like a no book.
Right.
Come on.
Can you imagine the fucking accidents?
Holy Shit.
This is what they're saying.
They're saying the Google cars have only had a couple accidents and they've been
running them through San Francisco for a while,
but people have,
I wonder how much the Google car accidents have been Google's fault.
It's so hard to drive Jesus Christ so hard.
I want my arms down.
He's still got to sit down.
It's so comfortable.
But you do you really not like driving.
I would rather have a driver but I don't want,
I don't trust a car.
It's too unpredictable.
You've got to make some razor sharp on the,
on the highway.
There's a lot of,
it doesn't have every situation programmed in the car.
There's all these weird awkward situations where you're just driving and you
could have avoided if you would have had control,
but are those weird awkward situations occurring because people are retarded.
Like if everybody had a driver car car that drove itself,
maybe those would just vanish and maybe you would get like a,
a green light when you get on the road.
How much you smoke man.
A lot.
But maybe thinking about it because like when you,
when you watch it,
like I'll watch this girl texting the other day on her phone and it was so
frustrating because we were on the highway,
we're going to like 65 miles an hour and a couple of times she came close to my
lane and whenever someone does that I go,
oh,
I guarantee you they're fucking with their phone.
And I look over on this.
Girls do it in this shit.
Everybody does that shit man.
Don't do that.
I don't do that.
I leave my fucking phone on the,
on the passenger seat.
I take it,
I put it over there.
I'm not fucking with that.
She'll talk and drive though.
I'll talk and drive on my phone on my,
I press a button on the steering wheel.
Yeah.
That's not bad.
Like because it's going through the Bluetooth.
You have a little conversation.
It's like you could see everything.
It's like having a conversation with a dude who sit next to you.
It's totally normal.
Is it legal to cause it's illegal to text or to do anything on your phone?
Yes.
Is it illegal to uh,
go through your CD's or go through your,
uh,
your,
stations on your side,
on your satellite?
You know,
you can do this,
but you can do this.
You can press the,
the,
the thing on your,
your car that's stationary.
It's like locked in.
But if you have something in your hand,
you start pressing that to make your music come on.
Which all my music,
because I'm my iPhone,
my,
I carry everything on my iPhone.
I carry all my music.
I never have enough.
I used to have an iPod connector.
Does that,
those are,
I still have it in my,
uh,
my BMW,
so I was a little iPod connector.
I still have iPods.
Why though?
My fucking phone is a hundred and something gigs.
Like there's no way I need all that.
Yeah.
Like you'd have to have every,
how could you listen to all that?
You greedy bitch and just,
you have to be a crazy person.
I think people are now since we went to were like,
it seems like more and more just using our laptops less and our phones way more,
way more.
Right.
So I think that's great for music.
Oh,
listening to music on your computer is not as cool as being out and about on
your phone.
You know with headsets and you can be drawn on the airport music that you can
send me.
You've sent me songs.
I listened to them right when you sent me though.
Like liver,
there's no delay at all.
Yeah.
How crazy be some of your shit.
And I press play and I'm listening to it in my car and then get some logins.
Oh,
it was good dude.
But in seconds,
in seconds,
like Le,
I mean you could,
you could ask Siri.
Now I'm going to stop this because people are getting mad at me for saying this
because it makes your phone go off.
All right.
If you say H,
e y,
Say those things together.
It'll,
you can ask it things like it'll transcribe things for you to transcribes for me
accidentally.
Just ice tea.
I down the phone is
like taking every word that I said accidentally because I said those words
during a podcast or something that sounded enough like it.
But when you have that,
when you,
when you do something like that,
you could tell it,
hey,
download me smoke serpent.
Uh,
Hey,
uh,
go to Eddie Bravo radio number three,
and it will fucking find it on the Internet and play it for you.
Dude.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
That's what we were talking about before,
before we started the podcast was my music conspiracy theory.
Oh yeah.
Well,
okay.
What's your music experience?
Right.
This is an Improv dot.
This is just me,
uh,
smoking a lot of weed and saying stupid shit.
But it seems that the record companies in the record business have always,
always ripped off the artist.
Artists never make that.
All of them.
When you look at documentaries,
every band the same thing.
They're getting ripped off.
If you watch that eagles documentary,
it's amazing.
I'm not an eagles fan.
I'll never buy an eagle's CD,
but I respect the shit out of him.
I respect the shit out of us on the ceiling.
I respect the shit out of them and they do got some good stuff,
but I'm just not that,
that,
that kind of southern rock,
they're all just prisoners here.
Device.
I love the story shit.
The documentary,
the story of how they got together and,
and their dynamics when they broke up and got back together and she did the
eagle stories and they like Hotel California.
It's all right.
It's not mine.
I'm doing too many strippers dance to it.
I put the story and then you watch,
uh,
like 30 seconds to Mars documentary and the record company is suing them for
like 30 million and explained that that's Jared Leto right?
That's the actor.
He also has a band.
His band had a deal with a record company and it all fucking went.
They just didn't get paid.
Basically.
It just,
they just never got paid.
They were huge.
Uh,
they got a couple of really good songs.
That echelon is one of my all time favorite songs.
But anyways,
uh,
you watch that documentary and it's always the same thing.
The record company doesn't have money.
They are not going to pay.
We had to pay all this shit for you.
We bought your fucking video.
We paid for.
You've got down producer,
you've got to pay that shit back and you better fucking get on the road,
motherfucker.
You Owe.
You owe us money.
This is the movie artifact artifact.
Sometimes we must fight in order to be free.
Okay,
I got something to watch on a plane.
Is that 30 minutes seconds to Mars?
Yeah,
that's the one on iTunes.
I would definitely was an iTunes and everything to buy for about a year,
but you've got to give it up to Jerry.
Glenn will cause he's the only guy on the planet.
It's a legitimate musician.
Rock star,
legitimate where he has millions of fans.
They sold millions of records and he's a very successful actor too.
You could almost say maybes reaching that a list.
It jarred Leto is a famous dude.
Nobody else has done that.
Music and acting that huge.
You've got to give it up and they got a couple of really good songs.
I'm not a gigantic 30 seconds to Mars Fan,
but echelon and the mission.
Absolutely fantastic.
So they uh,
they got a record deal and just were not getting any money.
You know,
I forget the details,
but they went to court it so they won't get any,
no.
What happened is they wouldn't get any money in Jared level.
Said,
I'm fucking out this motherfucker.
You guys aren't you guys?
Oh,
it's so much shit.
He wasn't going to say shit.
So he just said,
I'm going to make an album on my own.
Fuck this.
Right.
We sell millions of records,
we don't have anything and they're not giving us,
they're not paying us.
Right.
So the record company goes,
Oh,
you think you could just do that?
Like the record,
the contract was over like in six months.
Really.
They could have just waited it out,
but he just started working on a new album.
Said,
fuck that record company.
He goes,
oh,
he worked on an album.
That's our album.
You know what I mean?
Something like that.
Something like that where they ended up suing them.
You think you could just walk away from us?
How about we're going to come after you and for 30 million?
I have a friend who works,
she's a receptionist who was a receptionist.
She got fired.
She was working for some company that makes TV shows or some shit and they knew
that she was a comedian.
You know she's an amateur comedian and so while she was working with them,
she developed this idea for some pilot with her and her friend who's also a
comedian.
So then all of a sudden the company she's working for wanted to sign some
intellectual property agreement than anything she came up with when she was
working there would be there and they literally said to her,
why you work here?
We own your brain can just imagine how crazy that is.
Like she said,
she's a fucking receptionist,
comedian and funny comedian too and she's trying to make it,
you know,
she's out there hustling and the company that she works for that doesn't need
the,
they make TV shows,
they're not using her in that regard.
They're using her as a receptionist.
They just decide that somehow or another they're going to figure out a way to
steal from her.
We got to tap into her creativity and your ideas.
But imagine that,
and you're paying someone like dog shit money.
You're paying someone like receptionists pay and you want to own their dream,
their dream of a show that's fucking dirty dairy.
Every band goes through the same shit.
It's,
it's like the record company is owned by gangsters themselves and they go,
they're going to,
and when you sign a contract,
you don't give a fuck.
You're just this kid from the small town.
Your band got big,
you got to,
you're in Hollywood now,
you're going to sign the goddamn deal.
You don't even care.
You know,
you're getting ripped off.
It's so why it's so known that like everybody knows in the music business,
you don't make any money on your first album or two.
They'll make it so that you'll start making money on your third,
a four hour out album.
Uh,
that's where you're going to get a bigger cut.
But that for first album or two,
you ain't going to make shit.
And you know what?
It's bad.
It's good business to just,
when it's time for you to make the good money,
now we're just going to leave you on your own and find a new Os.
We always need to,
can't bring in the new ones.
There's always new R and B artist.
There's always new rappers,
there's always new ones.
There's new ones coming in,
new rock bands.
They're always coming in.
95% of them are going to fail and they want never make it to the third album,
but they got them coming to SAS.
They got to come in spirits you right,
because they all make the money and their second and third albums and the first
and the record company just leaves him.
Just get through it.
It's like an anomaly where you have a Depeche mode or youtube where they get
fucking massive and they could just sustain a career in 20 years into their
career.
A right fucking beautiful day and that's a smash hit once you like that.
Then at the,
at the v after 10 15 years,
you,
you own your own shit and you realize,
okay,
I'm going to do my own shit here,
but then get the majors to distribute it.
I'll use their distribution like with Dr Dre.
Did you know about what prince did?
He had to use a fake name to even use a next.
Now looking back,
everyone thought prince was crazy.
Prince is a fucking genius.
He came formerly known as Prince.
He's not friends anymore.
Nobody can say a shit.
He loved it.
Nobody could say the band.
Yeah.
They knew.
Well,
he proved a point to bitch should come and see me.
They're coming to see me.
They're not,
they don't give a fuck Obama with Warner brothers at a and M or,
you know,
that's all nonsense.
They just stole.
They were stealing.
Yeah.
You know,
they're trying to do that in the world of podcasting,
there's a,
there's a lot of that going on.
The world of podcasting where companies are coming in,
they're trying to own half of podcasts and put you on a network.
So I really comment.
It's been a lot of,
of a lot of that been going on where they're trying to scoop up podcasts because
podcasts are such a simple model and you have one,
you know how it is.
You take it,
you record it,
you upload it on on I,
uh,
iTunes with some sort of a,
a server.
It's not difficult.
Like,
you know,
use someone like a service,
like Libsyn is what we use that they,
they're actually in the podcast distribution business.
And once you do that,
I mean that's basically it.
That's all you have to do.
That's not a lot.
If someone like radio lab or like hardcore history is a perfect example,
he's almost always like in the top three or four,
whenever he releases something new,
maybe sometimes,
often one.
Number one,
I've seen them one a couple of times.
It's just a dude and a producer putting together a history podcast.
It's your podcast.
You had a direct impact on what's going on with marijuana today,
10 years ago before this podcast.
It's like it's,
I think you are the biggest spokesmodel the spokesmodel spokesperson
spokesperson for,
for uh,
for getting people to open their eyes.
You know,
cause you don't know about all that.
But I think the Internet is,
and I think I'm on the Internet.
That's what I think it is because I'm,
it's,
these are all my ideas.
These are ideas that I've gotten from reading all sorts of crazy shit that gets
sent me all the time reading different to the Messenger.
We are all,
we're all like conduits were all like rivers,
you know,
like some,
some,
some of us we tap into like a big ocean of information and we could shuttle that
shit downstream.
That's really what it is.
So what,
what,
when you get a podcast or if you know,
like someone sends me interesting shit on Twitter.
Oh I retweet things all day long,
all day long.
I always look at something,
I'll read it for a few minutes.
It just seems interesting.
I retweet it.
And that's why people say like,
are you endorsing things?
And you retweet hot it.
I found it interesting.
But make your own goddamn conclusions.
If I've,
right,
if I,
if something is totally ridiculous,
like some Christian Guy thinks that,
uh,
gays are responsible for the drought,
I will fucking retweet.
That doesn't mean I believe that.
All right.
I just think like,
Ha,
look at this guy.
I don't have time to like go through all the information with people,
but I'd like the fact that I'm this sort of portal.
So because of that I feel like,
um,
you know,
I,
I get
privy to,
or I get access to a lot of information that I might not have ever sought out
myself.
It gets sent to me.
It's really cool.
And then I do the same thing.
You know,
I talk about it on here and the w we'll sit around,
we'll try to think about it.
We'll try to break it down or figure out what's,
it's just another,
another river of the Internet.
That's what it is.
That this is all some new thing that's happening to the human race.
The human race gets to discuss things.
Uh,
once the Internet blew up,
that's when the music business supposedly went down and maybe it did go down
because record sales definitely went down.
They disappeared.
Pretty much all tower records closes down.
Virgin records.
Virgin closed down crazy,
but it's the same owners of these record companies.
They always told the artists they weren't making money.
Now this is my conspiracy theory now I think the music business is bigger than
fucking ever with the Internet.
They're not selling cds,
they're not selling solid product,
but I think they're making so much more goddamn money than ever before.
And why should they tell anybody?
Oh No,
you know what?
The record business sucks.
So now,
now you just want to get a record.
They making the money from online people.
The stuff is being sold through what?
Itunes.
Is that the number one?
The thing is,
yes,
people do steal music.
Wait a minute,
what are you saying?
No,
no.
I'm talking about,
I'm giving them the whole overall scope is that people do steal music.
I know that,
but I think when you go the old way where you're,
the only way you're going to get a CD is through the actual distribution.
You can't reach fucking but a fraction of the world unless you're gigantic and
go,
unless you're one of the big bands,
very hard.
You've got to have a physical copy.
But yes,
we're not selling cds anymore,
but now we have the whole on the whole world and they could buy it instantly.
I mean,
I can easily,
I'm okay with computers.
I'm like a blue bound computers.
I'm sure I could find a place where I can get free stuff,
but iTunes is so convenient and I got an iPhone.
I'm buying all my old vinyl stuff and,
and it's in my phone.
I think more than ever now.
Now that we're a phone culture,
I think music is bigger than Evernote.
I love music.
I'm so passionate about music.
I'm always hunting.
It's easier to find stuff.
Satellite Radio,
which is Sam Shizam is huge.
Anytime that I think now more than ever I think.
I think music is getting really good.
There's a lot of good artists out there and I think,
I dunno,
suck for awhile,
but I think there's,
there's going to be a new explosion of how we get and we get our music.
The record business aren't important anymore.
What's important is music.
We know it's important as music producers and an artist and everyone's losing
their own stuff and you can distribute stuff.
Soundcloud,
it's a totally different animal.
Now I'm making music.
I make a song.
Um,
I w I like if a independent label wanted to sign me as a producer,
whatever,
I would never take like an independent label.
I would take some deal.
That was a huge,
that was life changing.
But for me too,
it's just way easier just to do whatever I want to do,
not have to worry about anybody and just put whatever I want whenever I want.
I don't have any deadline.
Soon as you start getting deadlines and someone owns a piece on my motherfucking
music,
I dunno about that.
Not just a piece.
Most independent label,
you know.
No one's heard of.
That's going to be a huge label for me to honey.
Honey.
Had a problem with one of their last,
a song they had his last album.
There's this one song that I loved and I'm like,
why isn't that song on your album?
And even though they wrote that song they produce,
it was all there is the record company wanting to own it.
So it's like,
oh Jesus.
So they just decided to not put it on there and my dad is crazy.
That is crazy.
They just want to own it.
Someone else owns.
How crazy is that though?
And you sing it,
you write it,
you sing it,
you,
you experiment with it,
you change it.
And some do.
You don't know it all.
They own it.
It's theirs.
They want it.
They didn't pay anything for it.
They don't want to pay you for it.
They just want it.
It's part of the deal.
So it's like what,
what,
what exactly are the record companies needed for?
What are they needed for?
But you know what's going on is,
is w the music video,
MTV no longer exist as that music video,
TV station.
What are they now?
They just do it.
Let it like a regular channel now that's so weird.
But um,
they might show videos a little bit here and there.
I don't even pay attention no more,
but,
but uh,
why or a record labels still making these huge big budget music videos because
now everyone they do,
they'd go to vivo or youtube.
People love watching me at music videos now it's easy.
You could watch a music video now on your phone before you got to watch it on
MTV.
How are you going to get MTV on your phone now?
So there's like a resurgence of music.
Videos are huge and,
and music is so easy to listen to and share and buy and Shazamm and spread
amongst the music industry thrives on niches and you know,
metal people and R and B people r and B.
People aren't trying to sell music to these white kids that are in the insane
clown posse.
You know what I mean?
It,
it,
the music,
music industry is all about,
do you know your niche and,
and are you selling to the right market?
And that's what the Internet has become.
So for music,
I think,
I don't think the Internet killed music.
I think it's gonna.
It's gonna expire.
I think it's exploding right now.
Only killed these parasitic music companies.
That's what it kills.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
You don't go ripping it off.
Most people are buying the shoe.
They were distributors.
That's all they were.
They were distributors and promote publicists.
Now the public system or the publicist,
the best version of it is social media.
The best version of it is having a good connection with the fans on social media
and people finding out about your shit and they spread it virally.
That's,
that's the best way to do it.
And without that mean,
then,
then what happens is these companies,
like these big record companies,
they essentially become publicized.
We own your Twitter.
Yeah,
they will.
They do Twitter.
I told you what happened with him.
Well,
they tried to do that with me,
man.
They trying to own your Twitter
to,
they tried to post on it.
One of the TV shows I was doing,
it was one of the barrio wells.
They wanted to,
uh,
have access to my social media.
They wanted to use my Twitter and my Facebook.
Oh Shit.
And I was ready.
I was like fuck you.
This is no way to do that too.
Like a fan page type deal.
You know what I mean?
Like some like an extra one that I'm not really paying.
I'm not paying any attention.
You can create your own one.
You could do that shit.
He,
but if you sign off on that,
it's still no good.
Like yeah,
yeah,
yeah because you don't,
you don't know what the fuck they're pushed.
They're putting up there.
Unless you approve each and every message,
you know the best way to do it would be you tell me what you want me to say.
What are you trying to get me to say?
And I'll tell you whether or not that's ever going to happen.
And if you,
if you want to say something in my voice like cause which they're trying to do,
I'm like you're fucking crazy.
You're crazy.
Cause I'm,
I'm not going to agree.
Hey you guys should tune in to blah blah blah and prime time and eight amazing.
Like we would.
It'd be cool if you guys tweeted this like what are you out of your mind?
You think I'm a tweet?
Promotions for other shows or live tweet things that you've got going on or get
involved with your fucking shark week or whatever the fuck it is.
Like that kind of crazy talk like that's what happens when you become a part of
a network.
You,
you also become like involved in promos and they want to like they owned Arsenio
Hall's Facebook.
He couldn't,
couldn't get his Facebook back when he did that.
Arsenio,
the resurgence of the Arsenio Hall show it before on his own was his.
It was his was his butt to do in a new show.
That was part of the deal.
They wanted to take over his fucking Facebook.
That's crazy.
That's what they do.
That's what they do because that's all the power you blow up.
Some artists like Rihanna's Twitter,
she can just base on her Twitter.
She can make or break.
Bands are not really break.
I'm chicken,
make them.
She could do incredible stuff by herself.
She has all the power so she loses the label just with that Twitter.
Oh yes,
she owns her own show and Instagram and all those things.
That's all you need to do.
A lot of the deals now are,
I think the hour is going back to the people that everything is being set up in
record.
Labels are probably fumbling,
but they're still trying to Jack Young artists.
They're still trying to do shit to make it all that online money.
Yeah.
I don't know how much money that is.
I would Jamie,
what is the depth thing?
Online is a lot.
I know,
but I mean I want to know if there's ever been a study on what percentage of
music gets purchased online,
how much of it just gets downloaded illegally?
Like what do you think the ratio is?
I think most people you had to guess what the Spotify coming and non people
paying for that.
They can track that and people pay it and that's,
and that's,
that's problematic.
That's in a lot of ways,
a lot like a record company because that's one of the big complaints that
artists have had about Spotify is that they don't get paid enough money from it.
That's like Taylor swift's complained about it.
Really?
They're complaining.
Yeah.
They,
I think they're trying to get into the podcast world too,
but the point is like all they're,
they're like they're an aggregator right there a portal for something.
Like how much money should a portal make?
I mean,
what percentage should a portal make and what percentage should Taylor swift
make?
Taylor swift should make almost everything slowly for outlook of this frail made
only $2,700 in songwriter royalties from 43 million plays of happy on Pandora.
What the fuck?
What the fuck,
man?
Holy Shit.
That's like an onion sketch,
you know?
I mean,
that's like something the onion would write for an hour.
No big.
You have to be to make any kind of money.
$22,700 $2,700 for 43 million plays.
You know what?
Someone's going to start it.
Someone's got to start like a Pandora.
It's actually a musician.
Like an open source.
Yeah.
And say,
listen,
we're going to do this.
It's called tidal Jay z and a bunch of other,
I don't want to say all hip hop artists started it,
but they started something very similar.
Higher quality downloads.
It's you can pay $10 a month or $20 a month.
That's where that one Beyonce concert was for central park.
It was a special title.
Contracts.
We watched the artists make more,
supposedly they make more money,
but there was some backlash when that came out that are there people or fans
were staying like why do you need more money?
You already have money.
Let's let uh,
like uh,
independent artists get a chance to make some money.
It's really
what,
is he getting all the money from it or is it,
I don't quite little by little.
You see what,
what appears to be happening as little by little,
the artist is now because of the Internet is slowly the shift.
The power is going back to them.
Yes.
Yeah.
Cause once an hour.
Once you have followers and you can,
you can contact your fans.
You needed the record company to contact your friends.
How else are you going to contact your fans?
We don't even have cell phones back then.
Exactly what you need us to put you on the radio.
The radio head like really strict rules.
Like they had really strict relationships.
Radios lost all their power to man.
They're,
they're cutting budgets left and right.
Firing people.
You know Kevin and being are good friends of mine.
I do their show.
That's like the only,
the last tree terrestrial radio show I do.
They're really nice guys and I do their show and last time I was there,
been was there and he was telling me like they meet with like the upper
management but they're all,
everyone's negative.
It's all down.
It's all downer.
No one's like,
you guys are doing great.
It's such an enjoyable show.
Really appreciate that.
We're all working together.
Everyone's just like,
fuck,
we got to fire people.
We gotta cut tie.
It's like that business is,
it's a,
it's a kind of a dying business.
It's like Morse code because now that you have your music on your phone and
stuff,
I remembered.
It seems like just yesterday where I'm driving around,
I always had 55 cds in the back of my costs.
People stepping on them,
there's always cds and once every couple of weeks I've got to fucking organize
my shit.
There's just cds now.
Your phone,
it's just your phone.
It's so much easier and it's both the man instantaneously.
You could always,
if you don't have something on iTunes or whatever,
you could always go to youtube and listen to on Youtube.
No,
it's incredible.
It's an amazing time for that.
And now people,
these guys that were like Radio Djs,
essentially what made them cool was their personalities.
But when you get trapped in a Dj Gig like that,
you know,
people get little snippets of your personality and your thought process on
things and then you play another song and then like,
I think for those guys it's,
it's like it would
be way better served without a radio show.
They'd be way better served just talking about shit because that's what people
enjoy about them.
Anybody could play those same records.
You could have a robot voice that plays the same records of the people that are
tuned in just for the music therapy.
Go ahead and do it brother.
That people that are tuning in just for the music,
those people are going to tune in no matter what.
That's what they want to hear.
They don't care about the personalities but the personalities like guys like
Kevin and being their fun dudes.
They're interesting guys and that's what is interesting about that show.
Like they would almost be better served if the radio station fire them and they
had to go and do an internet show.
Cause if they did an internet show would just be them talking about stuff and it
would be great.
I mean,
you know just be podcast.
These,
I think for the longest time was fucking really hard to get the Internet on your
phone.
You know,
you had to download shit it was and then three g came around get a little bit
better but then four g LTE came around.
It's like that shit is fast as fuck.
Instantaneous streaming.
Like,
if you want to listen to a song,
there's almost never a hiccup.
It's really easy and really quick to do.
That's like,
that's such a game changer,
man.
That's,
so
if those,
if those djs there like a curator though,
where is it?
Where's the,
where do you find your new music these days?
Like a that,
cause that's kind of like if you're,
if you're considered yourself,
I guess like the Twitter curator for sort of that kind of content.
And that's really,
really good point on music.
That's a really good point.
That's why I'm so out of the fucking loop.
I don't know anything people tell me about some guy,
like Eddie was talking about the King Daddy Guy.
Never heard of him until he talked about to date daddy Yankee and it's just a
daddy Yankee.
Okay,
well whatever.
I never heard of that either.
But think about that.
You know,
Eddie found out and he's like,
I can't believe this guy's huge.
I just found out from him in real time on the show.
Like there's so many people that no one has ever heard of that are gigantic.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're talking about that King Daddy guy like I didn't find out about until you
just said it is massive.
He's playing the staple center.
Crazy.
Like a movie staple center.
King Daddy.
Come on.
That sounds like a Chris rock movie.
Well,
it's a,
it's just an amazing time.
It's an amazing time.
It's amazing time for promotion.
It's amazing time for,
you know,
it's amazing time to do podcasts.
I mean,
podcasts.
This is the craziest time ever for podcasts.
It's this new thing.
I mean we've been,
we've been doing it for six years.
Next month it'll be December,
like December 30th or something like that.
It was six years in that time.
Podcasts have gone from being some shit that people did for a goof too.
One of the ways,
one of the few ways that I get entertainment,
it's like one of the major ways my major ways are like walking dead,
like shows like that that I'll watch at home.
Hunting shows,
MMA fights and podcasts,
those,
it's a major part of like what I listened to,
not my own shit but like radio lab,
the Ted Radio,
the Ted podcast,
our a hardcore history Ari show show.
This is all these podcasts to listen to this always entertainment,
always,
constantly.
It's constant entertainment.
And I can't tell you how many fucking people I've talked to that say,
hey man,
listen to show him because your show,
we started our podcasts like anybody can do it.
Why not?
If it's good,
if you have one person take a fucking chance on your podcast,
one person and they go,
this is pretty fucking good.
And they send it to their friend dude,
eyelids.
Listen,
he's got shoot the shit about shit.
Like we saw it the other day when we were talking about um,
Josh Olin who uh,
we had it on the podcast.
We both watched a podcast that had like 2000 downloads on youtube maybe,
but,
and it was over a year ago and Jamie and I both watched it.
We both watched it cause we wanted to see these guys take on it.
So these guys take on it,
which was intelligent.
They're funny guys.
They were there,
they had good points.
They,
they gave us like an insight into it through now because of that,
I'll see that podcast and I'll go,
oh,
these guys,
I remember these guys and that's what people do and then do,
do,
do.
Next thing you know,
you've got 100,000 downloads a month.
I mean,
that's,
that's not unusual.
That's like,
that's super possible and plausible.
Now all you have to do is focus on something and put together something that's
really good and unusual and we all have friends like my friend Dave Dolan who
just died.
Let me tell you something.
If that motherfucker was alive,
if he lived in La,
I'd have him on the podcast every week.
I'm kicking myself that I never had him on while he was alive,
but he didn't.
He never comes to La.
That guy would be hilarious on a podcast.
If someone gave him a podcast,
like the fucking investigator chronicles,
the private investigator chronicles and you just let him be himself.
He could figure out how to be himself.
God would be hilarious.
But if
you could do stand up,
like in your podcast where you're talking,
you're telling jokes and everyone's connected to your,
your headset,
so you could hear people laugh though.
They would also start yelling shit out and then you shut down as soon as they
heckle button.
Boom,
they're gone.
Yeah,
but you would have to find them.
I try.
Would you find pick them out?
I mean how many people are on the line at the same time?
You know if you had to have a show like like a voice recognizer yeah.
If you do a show in a theater with a thousand people,
it can actually be kind of intimate.
If you say anything other than laughing,
you've got to record all your labs and only those sounds can come out and hear
the sounds.
You got cut off.
You're like,
ah,
yeah you got to do is Manny.
Cause then you get cut off and you find out why he got cut off.
But you don't get that laugh in.
There you go.
I get that.
Have to be express themselves.
You want people to be able to express.
If there wasn't hecklers or people respected you,
how cool would that be?
Where you could hear it might be like three or four people listening to
podcasts.
It's totally possible conference call.
Really exactly like a giant conference call,
but the problem would be like what I was saying,
like you can have a show with a thousand people in the audience and it's kind of
intimate.
It is kind of intimate.
You can make it intimate.
Yeah,
but but you're all looking at each other and that's what people,
that's the way people are supposed to talk describing a Webcam show there is
that bad.
You could do webcam sting.
Those guys don't talk.
There's no sound that true.
I made that up.
Imagine if the girl was like listening to all those guys jerking off
simultaneously.
2,700 guys and use here instead of like an audience cheering and laughing.
You see here 2,700 groans.
Just 2,700 dudes you could hear is them jacking off simultaneously.
I'm going to have to turn you down.
Don't be so ridiculous.
That's coming now.
That's coming.
Watch.
We're supposed to look at each house to live in the big Joe.
We could just sit there and smoke.
He's kind of doing that on periscope.
The sound.
He gets those little hearts though.
Did you watch the Astros podcast?
No,
I heard it was predicted.
I wanted me to do acid.
I wouldn't do it.
I want you to do it.
I didn't want to do it,
man.
I'm not,
I'm not like attracted to that kind of um,
experience acid.
That doesn't sound good to me.
What does it sound like?
It sounds like a horrible time.
No,
I've heard it's a great like Dunkin swears by it.
Maybe just talk to Duncan about it.
I don't think I'm program for it.
It'll be tried it when I was a kid and it was like a synthetic mushroom feel.
I'd rather have the real mushrooms.
I'm down with mushrooms but not a synthetic form of what's in Russia.
That's what I think it is.
I think LSD and acid is a synthetic form of mushrooms.
Right?
Similar.
There's similar like a lot of the trip to means they share like,
like,
like silicide been is really close to DMT and the way it's synthesizes and the
Bonnie,
it's like super close.
Like I'm going to butcher this,
but it's like n and a diamond field trip to mean and uh,
I think what is the silicide and version of it for Fox for a lock and,
and dimethyltryptamine something like that.
Like it's real close.
It's like they're,
they're kissing cousins,
they're all those,
the really powerful tryptamines,
they're all like neighbors of each other.
It's a very strange,
and they're all the closest to human neuro chemistry.
One of the most fucked up things about the really powerful psychedelic drugs is
the strongest ones like mushrooms and like DMT.
DMT is the strongest.
It's like an actual human neuro transmitter.
I mean it's not even,
it's not even like an addition,
like he's not even in addition to,
it was actually produced in your own body.
That's the weirdest thing ever about drugs that the strongest one we know of
your,
your own body makes like the fact that data that most people don't know that the
fact that most people know the Kanye West,
he's married to Kim Kardashian.
Most people don't know that your brain produces the most powerful psychedelic
drug that science has ever observed.
That's a nutty thing,
man.
That is a weird,
weird aspect of who we are as as human being.
What kind of a strange waking infantiles
civilization.
We are in the middle of like the greatest era of technological innovation ever.
Why Phi?
The ability to download songs instantly on phones,
like we were talking about the periscoping and fucking just in insane ability to
connect with each other.
At this day and age,
we still have illegal marijuana,
illegal psychedelic drugs,
illegal drugs like Bill Gates or a Steve Jobs said that LSD was what led him to
create an apple.
He said it was like one of the most important moments of his life is having an
LSD trip.
There's so many problems in this.
World's did so many different levels coming from all different angles,
from all different forms of life.
There's so much shit.
Everyone's trying to fight this.
They're trying to fight that they're into this.
They're into that.
Everyone's got their own cars,
but if we all got together and do what we did with weed and and,
and the legislation and all that stuff,
he did that with just one thing.
One thing.
We just focused all our power.
It would fix everything.
If we made it a law that he,
every politician has to do Iowasca
that'll fix all the prompts.
It would fix a lot if it would,
even if that's too much law even that's too much work.
You have them have one DMT trip a month while they're in office.
Yeah.
Just to keep,
everybody has to have a ceremony.
You get together and you meet with the elves and they tell you whether or not
you're fucking up.
Yup.
One law that's all.
Forget about all this other shit and we're scattering just one thing.
Make them do mushrooms or DMT.
That's part of being a politician,
just to make sure that the,
the odds are that you'll have compassion for the people and not let your greed
yeah.
Over and be interviewed while you're under too.
You have to approve,
you have to have a witness and that's what a videotaped put 'em under.
Then talk to them about life.
Yeah.
Have a sham and break flying all these guys from Peru,
like,
dude,
some chiller,
like they're going to fake like the Peruvian.
There's gonna be all this fake Peruvian,
big money.
Big money now.
Now that's a big racket.
I hate to break it to you,
but those leopard clause that dude has for earrings,
dumb shits of plastic.
That's fake.
Homeboys fake what?
Leprechaun.
I'm saying.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She got a flashy,
bigger Mexicans.
It's just cheaper if we just fucking Mexican.
Peruvian.
Very strong.
But you can't,
yeah,
you gotta.
You know,
they got to kind of look at Hiawassee call you my costs.
Right.
The past is that bringing Brazilians they know,
but you know what money going to get them.
We're going to put the cop or just like,
oh man.
It's nice.
Everybody.
Nice.
You're going to sit and watch my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Everything I do is for uh,
Iowasca I firefly WASC I live for and I was,
that was terrible.
That would change the world though.
It sounds like a junk.
But that would one law.
You imagine if you get like Dick Cheney and get them fucked up on mushrooms and
talk to them about life,
that would
be worth so much money.
How much am I like all these like capitalist dude's that you'll want to make
some real money.
Donald Trump this week.
Do you eat five grams of mushrooms on a Webcam?
If Donald Trump will try to raise money for his campaign and,
and that's what he said.
That was his,
his big,
that was his big gimmick.
He's going to take five grams of mushrooms on a Webcam and just talk to Skype
with people from all over the world and answer their questions about what he's
going to do to fix the world.
His hair would light it on fire.
Spontaneous combustion probably shaved his head halfway into the conversation.
I can't,
I can't do this anymore.
He probably look at cotton candy on my head.
I can't fucking hang with this anymore,
but I think that if you could do something like that just and make it something
that would be culturally acceptable,
like it sounds ridiculous now,
oh,
we're going to send the fucking presidential candidates down to the jungle and
make them do some drugs.
Like it sounds ridiculous,
right?
But if there was a culturally,
it's the only ridiculous because you have to leave the country,
which doesn't make any sense if you do DMT,
right?
One of the things that you feel is that you're not even there.
You've entered into some completely different dimension.
Some alternative coexisting universe is what it feels like you step into.
It doesn't matter if you do that in Peru or in Japan or on the moon.
It doesn't matter.
Like where you're going is has nothing to do with where you are.
It really has nothing to do with it.
It's only because it's illegal that people were forced to go to these indigenous
cultures and do it there.
If it was legal,
you can have a shamanically retreat center in America and people could go to a
shamanically retreat center and it could be treated just as respective as going
to,
you know,
whatever.
A psychiatrist or just as respected as going to a fucking a cancer doctor,
an oncologist or anybody.
Just getting your body checked out.
One of the only cut,
there's one of the only countries on the planet where Iowasca is praised and uh,
legal is the same country where they take a month off from work and party
straight.
Where's that?
Where's that Brazil.
They took a month off the carnival.
They just partied for a lunch.
Totally legal in Brazil.
I'll,
I'll get totally legal.
The UN trying to impose some shit and they're like,
dude,
fuck you.
You're not taking away.
I lost it.
Damn it.
We should move to Brazil,
dude.
Think about that dude.
Do you know how long have you had to take us to learn Portuguese?
Oh,
do you think I could do stand up?
I'll if I learned Portuguese.
Are you stand them in Brazil?
So like have you ever thought about end of the world scenarios?
If your thought about like if yellow's don't blows up,
where are you going to move?
I'm moving to Brazil.
Either Brazil or Australia.
Those are the spots.
Australia be way easier.
Everybody speaks English.
I just get to get used to the wrong side of the road or convinced them to drive
on the correct side of the road,
which would probably be better.
10 planets.
How American's thick I if I go to Australia I'm going to tell him,
listen faggots who stopped driving the left driving the right like a fucking
normal.
We invented the car.
I'll 10 planet
floor Annapolis.
Yeah that's going to happen.
Why not?
But do you think,
is it,
is it possible that you could see like the shit hitting the fan and moving to
another country?
Have you ever considered that?
Yes.
Where are you considered moving to?
Australia is nice.
Very nice.
You live in Melbourne's like Santa Monica.
I'm going there tomorrow for the first time.
My first time in Melbourne is Sydney's really nice.
I love Sydney.
Sydney is awesome.
They're cool as fuck.
They're,
they're real friendly,
very westernized,
very westernized.
Like you could totally fit right in there.
Like if you had to live in Sydney or the one place I've been,
but I'd be like,
yeah,
that's just like living in a nice city in America where people have a cool
accent.
Tell it would be it,
you know?
Did you go with me to Australia ever?
Did you ever do one?
The EOC is out this.
That's right.
Remember when we took over that bar and got blasted?
Yes.
Oh my God.
Joe went nuts.
He bought the whole bar drinks and oh my God.
Did we spend thousands of dollars?
I went crazy.
We just decided it was me and Tommy Segura and Eddie.
We had a whole day off,
so we went to see a,
that Leonardo DiCaprio movie where they trick you,
where he pretends you know it's all a dream.
No,
no,
no.
It was the other one.
Shutter island.
Yeah,
the island one.
We're both mad for all three of us.
We're mad.
We're like,
what the fuck?
You can't just do that.
Oh,
it was just a dream psych,
stupid fuck your dream.
And so perfect.
It's like one of the only times ever in my life that we just made a decision to
get drunk.
Like,
let's go get drunk.
let's go to a bar,
let's find a bar and get fucked up.
And we're like,
yeah,
let's do it.
We just all decided to go get fucked up.
Like there was nothing else to do.
There was a,
you know,
I didn't have a show until the next day.
So we went to this bar and just went off.
He just bought everybody drinks.
Everybody kept buying shots.
We bought hundreds of shots.
I don't even know how much money I spent.
It was insane.
We would literally,
we're just buying people drinks and high five and people and hugging people.
It was nuts.
We stay there for hours.
We were racked.
That was about as drunk as I've ever gotten as a grown man.
And then,
uh,
went back to the hotel room.
I think I threw up,
I don't remember.
And then the next day we had a show.
I think that was Joe Stevenson.
George Sada,
rob bliss.
Was it,
what was the main event that,
I don't know.
God,
there's so many fights now.
It's crazy.
How many or are shit,
it's impossible.
You she fee toward just take out Dan Henderson again,
head kick.
Damn.
Who would ever thought whoever thought,
you know,
at one point that was only one Brazilian.
They could box and his veto Morillo could box too.
And uh,
I think himso could box a little bit.
He had good,
you know,
if he towards kicks though,
they have changed his whole game because vittores towards always had hamper,
you know,
vittores
had like seven hand operations.
Yeah.
He's broken his hands like seven times.
So what do you think about
him being off TRT?
What do you think about that?
Well,
the reality is okay if it's not often,
if,
here's my,
my,
if he really needed it so bad that he said he needed it before and uh,
it was a medical issue.
His body was low on testosterone and he had to take it and then he took it and
there's just destroying everybody,
like looked like a world beater.
Like God damn,
remember when Vito was,
you got to think that he's probably fighting with load tests for a long time,
like the Matt Lindland days and a couple of days maybe even Sakharova fight like
no low test,
low testosterone.
Maybe remember we got off the guy when he was 19 and then Randy couture,
but okay,
that's true.
But do you ever see what he looked like when he fought rich Franklin?
He knocked out rich Franklin,
but go to rich Franklin versus Vito Belfort.
No,
no.
He smooth dude.
He doesn't look shredded at all.
And he's still bombing on rich Franklin.
He still had the skills and everything that he had,
but it's,
I think it might've been one of the reasons why he fade so quickly.
One of the reasons why he,
it's hard for him to sustain like a hard pace without the TRT.
And I think that a fight like the Dan Henderson fight points to the fact that
he's still super dangerous.
He's got nasty skills and really fast as fuck,
but he didn't do anything.
Look at them there.
Yeah,
I am against rich Franklin.
Look at his body.
I mean he's like real smooth.
I mean it doesn't look like a pipsqueak.
He still looks like an athlete for sure,
but it doesn't look like Vitorin the TRT days.
Not even fuck is this,
this is,
no,
this is before TRT.
See,
he's lost.
He fought like this and then he fought a Anderson and then and all the way,
by the way,
this is all after he tested positive for steroids.
The first time he fought in pride in uh,
Vegas.
He tested positive for steroids.
When he fought,
I think it was Dan Henderson.
He lost that fight.
But he tested positive for something.
Some metabolites.
No,
that was pride.
They don't test.
They did when they were in Vegas.
Well they had the one show in the United States.
They test it and that's the one show it.
Nikki has got popped fighting gummy member.
He got popped for weed and v tour got popped for steroids.
So when the side effect of using steroids,
and this is one of the reasons why a lot of people are against testosterone
replacement therapy for fighters,
is that when you use steroids,
your body stops producing testosterone on its own.
So you could get tested.
The steroids have since left your body,
but your body is not,
the endocrine system hasn't recovered yet.
So you go to the doctor and you go,
hey man,
I hear it's really low testosterone.
It doctors like we certainly do,
this is proof positive.
We have it here on the blood,
they do a blood test,
they get the results and they put the results against the commission and they
say,
hey this guy needs test.
And so they give him a testosterone,
a use exemption,
a t you eat.
And that was what all these fighters were getting.
But the complaints from the people that were clean or you know,
wanted everybody to be clean,
you know,
allegedly were clean I should say.
Was that the only reason why these guys have low test in their early thirties
like you know some of these guys,
like they had a guy that was 25 that was on testosterone replacement and they
liked the old and he looked like a tank.
And the only way a guy would need this at that age is if he abused the system.
If he took testosterone and fucked up his endocrine system.
So that was like the big argument against the testosterone use exemption.
So if you look at him right there,
now pull up Vito Belfort verses Luke Rockhold.
And this is a totally different animal.
I mean this doesn't even he,
this is like two years later,
right?
And he doesn't look remotely like the same guy.
I mean,
he looks like a Goddamn,
this was at the weigh ins by the way,
the weigh ins go up where he's throwing that.
We'll kick right there.
Bam.
Look at the fucking difference in his build,
Dude.
I mean,
what the fuck?
This is the same weight class.
Okay.
But he looks like he's fuck at least 10 pounds of muscle.
Bigger,
completely shredded.
That 10 pounds of muscle,
Luke Rockhold.
Yup.
That's after you smashed Luke Rockhold.
And so he was on TRT here.
Yes,
he was [inaudible] Gal.
Well,
I think Vitara ITRT fucking looks fantastic.
I think Vitara on TRT is one of the scariest fighters the MMA world has ever
seen.
It's crazy.
And I would have fighting and at that level,
and it's the highest level.
He's the only guy left.
Nope.
Yeah.
And he met Josh Barnett.
He,
I would have loved to have seen v toward like this tea,
RTV tor versus Weidman to your TV tour versus Anderson Silva.
I would've loved to see it.
I understand that it's not fair.
And I wouldn't expect Weidman to take that fight if he knew that [inaudible] was
on TRT.
I wouldn't expect it,
but Goddamn,
I would have loved to have seen it.
And no way Luke Rockhold is on TRT.
No Way.
Right?
Well,
even never say no way because guys have tested positive that looked absolutely
like shit.
You never know because they look like shit and the testosterone makes them look
a little bit better,
or the whatever they're taking makes them look a little bit better.
Sharma's bigger.
Look at his arm and then look at B12.
RUCC.
Rockhold first of all is taller,
so if he's going to weigh the same amount,
he's going to have less muscle.
There's just no way around it.
It'll be longer.
And look,
he gets a lot of harm right there.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God,
he's so,
Jack's like Mark Kerr,
but Luke Rockhold is a fucking savage.
I mean that dude's a stud.
He's one of the toughest guys in the sport and real smart,
real technical.
But TRT v Two r ran him over,
TRT v tore wheel,
kicked him in the fucking head and beat him down and he beat down Dan Henderson
like that.
He knocked out Michael Bisping with a head kick and fucked his eye up
permanently.
Michael Bisping's eye is permanently disfigured because of [inaudible] kicking
him in the head.
This is like,
he's one of the scariest guys in the history of the sport.
When he was on TRT,
it was like a four fight run or he was just fucking smashing people.
And that Dan Henderson fight was one of the most devastating cause it wasn't
just the kick.
He had uncorked a fucking left uppercut before that kick hurt him real bad.
And then head kicked him and knocked him out.
He was a fucking terrifying when he was on TRT.
So he's more tentative now.
He didn't do a single thing for the first two minutes in this fight.
He literally didn't throw a punch or a kick.
He just circled for two minutes.
And then,
you know,
Dan threw a couple inside leg kicks.
There was a couple of little whiffs,
you know,
nothing really connected.
And then v torches on corks.
That head kick.
So the question is,
when you look at v tour now,
he definitely looks better in this fight that he did in the Weidman fight.
He looked more built,
but he still didn't look like he looked when he was on TRT.
So even if he had,
look at that shot down,
was punching Dan Henderson in the head.
Look at that.
Jesus fucking Christ build on him.
Dude,
he looks like a lion.
Look at his neck like,
look at the fucking traps on this guy when he's throwing this punch and he's
connecting perfectly on Dan Henderson's.
John,
that shot.
That is a classic picture.
He was a monster dude,
but the question is like,
what is he doing now?
How's he?
If he needed testosterone replacement before,
like how was he,
how was his body recovered like this?
Like what does he,
is it as he figured out some nutritional way to get around it or is he figuring
out some undetectable way to use no one else,
you know,
we're not going to know unless he gets caught based on what his body looked like
in his last fight against Dan Henderson.
W would you,
do you think his body looks like he's not on it or definitely doesn't look like
Tim Kennedy said it was best.
He said it doesn't look like vittores is using as many steroids.
Tip Kennedy's hilarious.
He said he wanted to fight the slow.
I'm interested in the fight.
He said with a slower fat or fee door.
Meanwhile,
it looks like he does steroids too.
Well to generate,
he's a tank at dude.
I'm not saying he does,
but fuck is yoked Danny's five,
10.
He walks around at 220 pounds.
[inaudible] steroids and I'm saying I got out.
I wouldn't be like,
oh my God.
I know.
Right.
Well you know,
who the fuck knows?
Who knows who's doing it?
Who's not doing it?
It's w I'm a fan of has not by the line Tim Kennedy.
That was a compliment.
It's a compliment I think.
Um,
you know,
I just did it.
Did that,
you know why I say I don't like that?
Like I think like,
um,
like can you,
uh,
control what we see or is he controlling?
We can do it if we set it up,
I can connect to apple TV in the future for you,
man.
If you could just,
cause you're really good at looking through shit.
Yeah,
but it's distracting.
It's better to have Jamie do it because I like to engage with the person I'm
talking to.
I don't want to look down and type shit in.
I'd do that occasionally,
but I think it's best.
We figured out a rhythm.
Yeah,
I get it.
I got to get out how to do this shit.
But um,
so Rhonda is fighting in Australia in front of 70,000 people this weekend,
that's for sure.
70.
Yeah.
Well they had sold like as of a couple of weeks ago.
They were already like 50,000 tickets sold.
Remember those people who thought Rod let women's MMA would never make it.
How about Dana?
It was so many people didn't think so.
It has to be someone like her though.
What's interesting is like a Yolana,
the strawweight champion.
She's like scarier than Rhonda.
When she beats people up,
she smashes her face.
And for me,
and I think a big part of the reason,
there are those people that that thought a women's MMA would never make it and
they still holding onto that.
They think that Rhonda was just a freak in the after her.
It's over there.
So it's still some people.
But the reason was I,
everyone kind of thought that at first too,
because in the beginning,
back in late 99 2000 the girls that were doing MMA had no skill.
They had nothing.
They were so,
it looked like,
man,
girls really can't fight.
They,
I even doubted it.
But that one time in Vegas where we,
when I forget what show,
it was tough.
It was tough enough and there was some girls going,
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
So much fun right there.
That's when I became pro female MMA.
That's when I thought,
wow girl,
people like watching girls pull their hair and,
and scratch each other.
We like watching that.
We'll watch out on a second big,
you know,
we watched it on Worldstar was at a time we went there to see nick the goat
Thompson fight member.
He was the main event.
That's right.
Yeah,
like Thompson.
That's interesting too.
I forget who that girl was.
Smart Guy.
He was like a law student.
Put your cap legit Jujitsu.
That's the first time I saw legit ah,
Jujitsu and a women's MMA fight.
I don't know.
It was like 2098,
nine and then,
uh,
and then with Jeff Osborne,
did you know he,
he's the original in victim who can shoot?
Yeah.
Well Osborne put on Eve Edwards versus,
uh,
Aaron Riley,
Aaron Riley in like 90 fucking six or some shit.
When was that fight?
I don't remember the year,
but it was like,
it was 99,
maybe not the same era of Mecca.
And uh,
remember the valley Tuto the Ivc those days,
the Pedro Pedro,
that's,
that's like,
uh,
you know,
talking about those days.
It's like in,
in metal.
That's the equivalent to the German thrash scene.
It's just like that.
Remember that Mecca and IVC to most people don't know what that is.
You remember that dude?
The Pedro Gary Goodrich reached down in his pants and grabbed his dick.
Yeah,
I made Derrick may carry Goodrich,
reached down and crushed his guys balls and with happy with his feet and his
hands too though.
Right?
He did it with his feet only with his feet.
I tell you,
I'll tell you what,
Eddie Bravo
turned his nuts into peanut butter.
That's some fun.
That's what he said.
Word for word guys can get there.
Pedro versus very good Ridge nut shot.
Yeah.
The Pedro versus Gary Goodridge.
Uh,
not smash.
Yeah,
testicle crunch.
He loved it.
You were allowed to do that back in the day.
Grab the ropes.
Keith Hackney versus Joe Sohn had Joe Sansai controlled Josiah and held onto the
head the head lock.
It was before the von flue choke was invented.
Punching his ball.
He's just wailing on his balls wailing on his ball.
That's the new era.
Eventually it's going to be MMA were balls or legal.
God damn the balls are in play.
The game we had that sketch religious extreme sacrifice.
That's the next lobby was going to be the champ cause he had the littlest balls.
Dude,
you make,
you make em ball shots,
legal and,
and the ne it no good.
Everything.
You don't keep your hands up.
You keep your hands low.
Okay.
What's going on here?
What do you say
to the no,
he like grabbed his balls.
Extreme sacrifice.
He might have not remembered it.
Right.
Honestly,
I kinda remember him doing it with his hands.
He does it with his feet.
It's with his feet.
This is Gary.
Good,
rich in pride.
That's in pride.
It's definitely not it.
It's not an ad either.
That's that's Pedro,
his own.
It's,
it's actually the Pedro.
Pedro.
Yeah.
You know it might be one of those ones where nobody has it.
Here we go.
Gary Goodrich.
Go down to the page or the fourth one down.
Click on that.
Let's see if this is it.
This is the Pedro,
but this is him.
But that's not Gary Goodrich fight and that's somebody else.
Oh,
this is a highlight reel of the Pedro.
And you know what?
He's not going to show that.
He might,
he might just say,
look at this and I want to know about that guy.
I want to know about the Pedro.
That guy was a,
he was like pioneer.
Yeah.
Looking at these old school nets,
these two,
but nets around the ring.
Well,
they used to fight and rings like people don't know that chocolate.
Dell fought a fucking Palae.
Palae,
Jose Landy,
Jose Palae,
Landy Johns who was at the time the baddest motherfucker from shoot box Palae
was up beast man when he was young,
he was devastating.
He was like the leader of the chute box crew and he was one of the best and um,
chocolate Dell fought him.
No rules with fucking bare knuckles.
That's a wild ass fight.
I'll you a UFC fanatics that are under 30 I mean you got to know your history.
We got to go back and study.
It's like,
to us it's like studying the 30s and forties we got to go back.
Look at the 60s you've got to look at that old school stuff.
So I have a masters did it.
I VC and what was the other one called?
Remember when Marco [inaudible] Penda he was the first time in a while.
Yeah,
that's right.
What was his,
his organization called?
It was either IVC or Mecca and they showed the jungle.
It was two dudes as far but equal law panda.
And then there was another guy that's got some series that was late nineties
Mna.
Bare knuckle.
How about when Marco who was fought all leg tack tar off in a hotel in Brazil.
They had like a chandelier above the ring if fought in a ring.
I don't remember that or not.
Yeah,
I had,
I had it on VHS.
It's the most ridiculous scenario.
They're like,
well yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They fought bare knuckle.
It was like a slow methodical find.
Um,
find that uh,
Marco who asks are you a ass all leg tack tar off?
They fought in Brazil.
It's in a ring and they have this like ridiculous like chandelier above the k
above the ring.
You'll like looking at this chandelier.
What the fuck is that?
Where are you like a name Marco who was old leg tack tar off.
He was one of the original fighters in the UFC.
The first ever that I ever heard of sambo before.
I'd never even heard of it before.
Yeah.
This guy was throwing up these leg locks.
It's hilarious when you look at it like we thought all exact offers a leg lock
master.
You compare him to someone like Eddie Cummings and you look at like how the leg
lock game has changed in 20 years because is radically changed to the point.
Like people have figured out all these crazy new ways to control and enter and
we used to think that all ag tech tarp was the,
he was a tough pregnancy.
One Hanzo up kicked him and knocked him out.
That was world combat championships,
right?
The WCC or something like that.
That was the same one where Tom Erickson fought Marillo Bustamante for like 90
minutes.
Oh,
Shamba that.
Yeah.
Tom Erickson was like 300 pounds.
He was a beast to aid.
Two was shy and Tom Erickson was the first a male,
a male,
but heavyweight.
Unbeatable forth.
Tom Erickson came along.
He came along.
He uh,
he fairing did,
he'd having took his back in,
in pride.
He got tired.
Tom got Tired.
Yeah.
This is it.
Like,
look where they are.
They're in a fucking there.
Like some angles you get to see like,
I guess actually with that thing above their head.
This is crazy.
Like
it's hard.
You see it from this angle as far as fight.
This is crazy.
Oh,
he take,
Tom just landed some good shots.
Bare knuckle of how long?
It doesn't go far.
I was a long ass fight.
It looks like 30 minutes.
It says.
Um,
but they um,
they fought in like a conference hall,
man.
This is after they had both left the UFC.
It looks like a place where you'd have to look at that.
Look at the ceiling,
looking at fucking chandelier.
What is that?
That's nuts.
It's bizarre.
Oh,
throwing down a look.
Just tagged him and be like,
we thought like Marco.
Who else at the time?
It was like a world class striker.
You know,
it's interesting.
He was really good for MMA.
He was really good at a bunch of different things.
But if you compared him back then took,
I like Andy Hook who was fighting k one at the same time.
Who was a real world class striker or a guy like Jerome Le Banner or,
or you know,
Peter Arts is a big fucking difference.
Marco,
who was first got his leg kicks successfully in the UFC hall.
Varlands chopped down the fucking fire.
Another one.
You youngsters,
Paul Varland and Marco who asked me,
Paul violence was the first pigeon toed giant American male to fight in the UFC
two giant.
It's been a couple of those
style.
I don't remember what trap fighting.
Is that what they called it?
Oh my God.
He's a master of trap.
A lot of those guys had some great eve Edwards takes the cake though.
Thug Jitsu Thug Jujitsu master.
That's still his,
uh,
his Twitter handle,
which is funny now because he's an analyst for Fox and his Twitter handle is
thug Jitsu.
He might have to change his shit.
He's a really good analyst man.
He was on like a UFC inside or wherever the fuck it is.
What do they call it?
Yeah,
he was on after the fights,
analyzing the fights,
breaking down the fights this past weekend.
The detour.
And I didn't know he really wanted the roster.
Yeah.
Well he's doing an analyst's work now,
so he's not fighting.
No,
he's retired.
He's retired from fighting,
but his,
his analysis was really fucking good,
man.
He,
uh,
he,
the Anthony Burchuk Thomas made a fight.
He was excellent in that.
Excellent.
Yeah,
he's very good.
Commentated it,
no,
after the fight he broke down.
What,
what happened,
you know,
he broke down and they'll talk about like what guys have to do in order to win
the fight and what,
what their best strategies are.
He's very smooth man.
Very good.
Very mean.
You know,
Eve's fought,
like we said back in the hook and shoot days when he fought Erin Riley,
which just like the 90s,
he's been around for so long.
I mean he's,
he's got so much information in his head and even though he lost some of his
fights towards the end,
he hasn't,
he hasn't like suffered in the,
to the point where he's hard to hear,
communicate,
you know,
he's very smooth,
very good communicator.
So he's smart about when he got out he was like,
you know what,
I just stepped back now.
And so he's like,
still got all his faculties.
He is excellent as a,
as an analyst.
Those are the best analysts like Dominick Cruz.
He's one of my favorites too.
Super Smooth.
And you know,
and also Dominic is just really hard to hit man.
He's,
he's not a guy that gets hit a lot.
He's like a big part of what he does is like avoid damage.
He's very smart like that.
Like you very rarely see that guy in like a crazy slug fest,
you know?
So because of that,
I bet he'll have a long career in being an analyst after he's done fighting too.
It's amazing that there's so many football analyst after all the head trauma
they go through.
Yeah,
it's things they just pumped.
Those dudes fill with Adderall and steroids,
windup ass and just push him out there.
Is there something that you can take out there that's on the black market that
just makes your brain mushrooms for real?
For Real?
Mushrooms is supposedly silicide was one of the few things that's supposed to be
able to regenerate neurons.
Whether or not that's true.
I don't know her joking.
No,
I read that Amber Lyon,
stuff like that.
I read stuff like that and then I closed my laptop because I don't even want to
know the details.
A mage,
just going to just start repeating the,
you know,
I don't know if it's true.
The last time we talked to amber lions emailed her really recently.
She's gone on some wild trip all around the world and she's a little psychotic
drugs.
Oh,
she's doing everything,
man.
Everything.
What do you got?
She's doing it.
She's trying out shit and all these indigenous cultures traveling all over the
world,
writing about the time she was on your podcast.
Yeah,
she didn't,
she was all business.
It was all that reporting.
CNN Shit had nothing to do.
And during that podcast you started talking about mushrooms and you were going
off and you,
you,
uh,
broke
it all down and she's sitting there and she was in a real bad spot and I like
her life was falling apart at that point and she just decided,
fuck it,
I'm going to Peru or wherever she went.
And South America,
she was by herself one sock.
She didn't take shit.
She just went,
she comes back and she's like a crusader for silicide been crazy shit saying
sometimes you find the right people.
We got one minute,
Jesus Christ anymore.
It's over.
Well,
let's do another one before Ebi,
the Ebi,
which is December 15th.
Does that Sunday,
December 13th 13th.
This is our town,
la.
You could order it on paper view.
I had butoh videos.com/ebi.
Um,
and so that will be the weekend after the UFC.
Yeah,
right after Connor Mcgregor.
It's the next day downtown bitches.
She'll start to five o'clock.
You can get your tickets at Ticketmaster to 16 man submission only tournament is
the deepest,
darkest bracken ever.
Denny Perkopolis Bitterman champion,
uh,
Nathan Orchard,
honey,
I ya go listen,
I blobby Hafael Domingo's Kim Tell Havi Vasquez Reuben Alvarez leg lock,
Ma a master from the southeast.
This is seriously,
every show gets harder and harder to win.
Winner take all $20,000 possible.
The winner gets passed to win four matches.
He gets paid 5,000 for each matchy wins in regulation.
What's the a website real quick because we're out of time.
Eddie Bravo,
invitational.com.
That's it.
Eddie Bravo on Twitter.
We'll see you fuckers.
I'll see you when I get back from Australia.
Follows.
Thank you,
sir.
Hmm.